Okay, dann kann es jetzt losgehen. Willkommen zum Blue Moon. Heute mal wieder eine Ausgabe von Chaosradio. Im Studio sind Martin, Pavel und Andy vom CCC. Hallo.
Morgen.
Moin, moin. Ich bin Sabine. Also ich bin Johnny heute sozusagen, weil Johnny ist im Urlaub.
Ich dachte, der ist hinüber.
Ja, der war hinüber.
Darum muss er in den Urlaub.
Aber er zuckt noch.
Ja, der liegt am Ostseestrand.
Wie bei deinem Wetter?
So wie ich das so sehe, ist das die erste Show um neun Jahrtausend. Ziemlich lange Funkstille vom Chaosradio.
Ja, wir mussten uns besinnen.
Ja, ich weiß. Die letzte Sendung war, wenn ich das richtig sehe, vor dem Kongress.
Genau.
Vor dem Chaos Kongress, der zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr war. Ziemlich viel passiert in der langen Zeit, wo man von euch nichts gehört hat. Ihr wollt aber heute Abend nichts vom Kongress erzählen, oder?
Na, wir können ein bisschen was erzählen, aber eigentlich ist es nicht das Thema der Sendung, weil der Kongress, das war dieses Jahr insofern sehr entspannt, als dass wir...
Irgendeiner atmet hier ganz schrecklich. Bist du das Martin?
Ich bin das sehr...
Du darfst da nicht reinatmen.
Ist besser so?
Also sehr komisch. Das war deswegen entspannt, weil wir alle ganz entspannt durchgeatmet haben. Wir haben nämlich aus reiner Schlamperreis irgendwie nicht geschafft, die Presse zu informieren und irgendwelche Agenturmeldungen zu erwirken oder sonst was. Das heißt, die Veranstaltung war rein über das Internet angekündigt und es war total prima, weil das waren halt eine Menge Leute da.
Waren man unter mich sozusagen?
Ja, nee, denen man halt auch nicht mehr so das Allergrundsätzliche erklären musste. Und das war nicht so, wie man teilweise letztes Jahr das Gefühl hatte, dass man da zwar ein bisschen unter sich ist, aber dass dann irgendwie auch andererseits Teil eines Zoos ist, wo Leute einen so angucken, als sei man irgendwie im Käfig und so ein exotisches Tier mit bunten Flügeln irgendwie, was zwar irgendwie auch mal lustig ist, aber auf Dauer, auf drei Tage Dauer dann doch auch mitunter ein bisschen latent verspannt wirkt. Ja, das war soweit.
Ihr hattet Spaß.
Wir hatten Spaß, ja.
Ja, es ist wirklich viel passiert. Kevin Mitnig ist aus dem Knast raus. Es gab ein Urteil zum Reverse Engineering beim DVD, Kopierschutz. Aber ihr habt was anderes für heute Abend.
Genau, wir haben uns überlegt, dass, also bei dem, was jetzt gerade in letzter Zeit passiert ist, wir uns mal wieder einem gesellschaftlichen Thema widmen wollen. Wir haben das Thema der Sendung mal Bugs im Betriebssystem der Bundesrepublik Deutschland genannt oder auch Shutdown-Skripte für Volksparteien. Wir wollten also diesen aktuellen, ja, nennt man das Skandal oder wie nennt man das, die aktuellen Ereignisse im Zusammenhang mit dem Club der Unwissenden, anderen auch als CDU bekannt, mal zum Anlass nehmen, über sozusagen, naja, verschiedene Stränge zu reden. Mitunter wird ja den Illuminatenfreaks immer vorgeworfen, sie würden Verschwörungstheorien warten. Wenn man sich die Zeit und in der letzten Zeit anguckt, hat man eher den Eindruck, die haben Recht. Aber auch das soll nicht das Thema der Sendung sein, sondern wir wollen eigentlich sozusagen mal versuchen, wenn wir das Grundgesetz mal als Betriebssystem nehmen und die politischen Parteien als Programme und die Bürger als, ja, auch da irgendwie Rammbausteine vielleicht und die anderen Bestandteile ebenso sehen, wenn wir das Ganze sozusagen mal als Technologie begreifen, was läuft hier eigentlich schief? Was läuft hier eigentlich schief und was könnte man anders machen? Also haben wir ein Betriebssystemproblem oder haben wir ein Programmproblem oder was ist ja eigentlich, was so gewaltig stinkt?
Ja, und natürlich geht uns auch einiges ziemlich auf den Senkel und da wollten wir natürlich auch die Gelegenheit nutzen, vielleicht an der einen oder anderen Stelle unseren Senf dazu zu tun.
Ja, ich finde einfach jetzt der Hammer, was im Moment passiert. Ich habe mich heute mal informiert irgendwie im Internet über die CDU. Bis jetzt hat mich die Partei noch nicht so besonders interessiert, muss ich sagen. Es ist die Partei, die mein Opa gewählt hat und er hat auch seine Gründe dafür, weil es ganz klar ist, er wollte nicht, dass die Sozis dran kommen. Und ja, das steht irgendwie auf der Homepage unter Wir über uns, unser Selbstverständlich. Wir sind eine Volkspartei der Mitte. Grundlage unserer Politik ist das christliche Verständnis von Menschen und seiner Verantwortung vor Gott. Unsere Grundwerte Freiheit, Solidarität und Gerechtigkeit sind daraus abgeleitet. Die CDU ist für jeden offen, der die Würde und Freiheit aller Menschen und die daraus abgeleiteten Grundüberzeugungen unserer Politik bejaht. Und so weiter und so fort, blablabla. Also noch ungefähr 20-mal das Gleiche. Und ich finde es einfach der Hammer, dass die das auf ihrer Homepage schreiben.
Was hast du erwartet?
Na ja, ich meine, das hätten sie mal ändern müssen. Es gibt ja auch so ein interessantes Chat-Forum im Internet, auf dem diskutiert wird. Da gibt es jetzt also auch einen eigenen Chat über Parteispenden. Wurde wahrscheinlich angelegt irgendwie. Und der Server bricht also halb zusammen. Ich war da heute morgen mal so ein bisschen drin. Irgendwie bei jedem Reload erscheinen drei neue Beiträge und fünf alte verschwinden wieder. Also die CDU-Redaktion hat momentan alle Hände damit zu tun, irgendwie die schlimmsten Beiträge zu zensieren. Sie geben auch ganz offen zu irgendwie auf ihrer Seite, dass sie zensieren. Die Begründung ist mehr oder weniger, naja, kann ja jeder nachlesen irgendwie. Also auf Deutsch gesagt, ja, was uns nicht passen muss, der muss ja nicht auf unserer Homepage stehen, ist ja unsere. Ja, dementsprechend macht viel Spaß irgendwie. Und mein Eindruck ist halt eben...
Also ist das sehr ein eigener Chat sozusagen?
Jaja, sicher, klar.
Also sie benutzen die Mittel des Internets und die Kommunikation, die da möglich ist, um sie dann wieder auszuschließen.
Lässt du dir jeden Mist in dein Gästebuch reinschmieren?
Ja, ich bin ja nicht die CDU, ich muss da nicht so viel befürchten. Na, ich hatte gehofft bei dem heutigen Thema, einmal muss ich sagen, ich bin super erleichtert, dass es nicht um Ramsprachen geht heute Abend. Das wäre für mich... Ja genau, da bin ich dann... Da halte ich mich lieber raus. Aber ich hatte ein bisschen gehofft, dass es so beim Thema Verschwörungstheorien, also wenn wir das anreißen, dass es auch so ein bisschen lustvoll zur Sache geht, weil Verschwörungstheorien machen einfach höllischen Spaß.
Ja, ist richtig.
Gibt es auch eine Spaßkomponente heute?
Die gibt es auf jeden Fall. Ich muss dazu aber sagen, ich habe heute sehr lange mich mit vielen Leuten auseinandersetzen müssen, als ich versucht habe, einen Ankündigungstext für die Sendung, den wir üblicherweise über einen E-Mail-Verteiler rausschicken, der jetzt vielleicht auch an mir nicht rausgegangen ist, ein bisschen mit den Leuten hier abzustimmen. Ich hatte da ursprünglich so einen Satz drinstehen, der mir eigentlich logisch erschien, wenn der Bundeskanzler Kohl sozusagen der Honecker der Bundesrepublik ist, ist Schröder dann vielleicht der Grenz der Übergangszeit oder so. Und ich hatte das also versucht, auch ein bisschen auf die Lustige zu nehmen und zu sagen, naja, ist doch eigentlich, hat Politik in den letzten Wochen, ja, man kann darüber schlechtes haben, was man will, aber der Unterhaltungswert ist ja extrem gestiegen. Also nie haben sich so viele Leute amüsiert, weil nie wurden...
Und mit Politik beschäftigt dadurch.
Genau, weil so viele Machtzusammenhänge so deutlich wurden.
Na ja, na ja, na ja, so 1989 haben sie auch viele Leute mit Politik beschäftigt.
Ja, aber ich glaube, die hatten nicht so viel Spaß, oder?
Na ja, ich war nicht dabei, aber die Demos...
Na ja, was mir darum wiederum interessant ist, ist ja, dass diese Schreiber-Affäre ist ja schon vor Jahren, hat die schon in der Zeitung gestanden, in der Süddeutschen. Ja, und da ist es nicht auf so Publisse die Boden gefallen, da hat sich eigentlich keiner so richtig drum gekümmert, erst mal. Also jedenfalls nicht in dem Ausmaß wie jetzt. Das ist ja auch wichtig, vor dem Hintergrund damals, cool, unangreifbar und so. Und heute sieht das ganz anders aus. Es ist auch kein Zufall, dass das so doll ausgebreitet ist.
Das ist auch kein Zufall, weil das alles eine Affäre ist. Aber da können wir später drüber sprechen. Das ist nur eine Affäre, die ab und zu mal anders genannt wird.
Na jedenfalls hatte ich so ein Verschwörungstheorie-Sendungskonzept eigentlich schon geschrieben und es wurde mir dann wieder ein bisschen ausgerettet, weil eine Menge Leute, mit denen ich geredet habe, gesagt haben, ist ja richtig. Aber eigentlich ist das zu ernst, weil, dass jetzt irgendwie alle Verschwörungstheorien sich im Moment bestätigen so, das ist irgendwie okay und jetzt aber noch weiter Verschwörungstheorie zu spinnen, das würde den Ernst allein nicht ganz treffen. Weil die Frage ist ja tatsächlich, wie geht es weiter so? Bei der SPD hat man ja auch nicht durchgehend den Eindruck, wir kommen gleich noch zu so ein paar Details, beispielsweise diese Akten, die Leuna-Akten, die aus dem Kanzleramt verschwunden sind. Die sind ja unter denselben Verantwortlichkeiten beiseitegeschafft worden, die da heute noch herrschen, zumindest was die Mitarbeiter betrifft und so fort. Und die Frage ist ja, hat sich da überhaupt was geändert? Und haben wir ein CDU-Problem oder haben wir ein Politikproblem? Und wenn man sich jetzt sozusagen mal die Auswirkungen auf die Fläche anguckt, dann hat man ja schon den Eindruck, viele Leute haben jetzt einfach den Glauben an diesen Staat und die Regierung und die Demokratie auch komplett verloren. Deswegen sollten wir vielleicht nicht nur über Verschönerungsregeln reden, sondern auch über Alternativen. Weil wir haben ja auch einen Maß an Transparenz über Internet und so fort, was andere Formen eigentlich möglich machen würde, wo aber die konventionelle Politik aus verständlichen Gründen, man will ja auch gut bezahlt sein und so weiter und so fort, im Moment noch nicht das Interesse signalisiert hat.
Ich finde, also für mich ist das der Punkt. Die Leuna-Akten, die verschwunden sind und die Feststellung, ich weiß nicht mehr welche Justizstelle das war, Gericht so und so, hat gesagt, es gibt nicht mal eine Anklage deswegen, die werden nicht mal gesucht. Das ist für mich im Moment der interessanteste Punkt.
Was ist für dich der interessanteste Punkt? Also wie reagierst du darauf? Also das ist doch eigentlich die Frage. Also für mich ist eigentlich die Frage irgendwie, wir sind hier vier Bürger, wir sind keine Politiker, wir sind politisch mehr oder weniger interessiert und wir haben eine Meinung. Also ich meine, ich finde es nicht schlimm, dass da irgendwie mal ein paar Millionen in einem Koffer von hier nach da geschoben werden, weil es macht eh jeder. Für mich ist einfach die Frage irgendwie, welche Partei kann ich überhaupt noch wählen oder was betrifft mich das? Also ist das jetzt schlimm, ist unser Start am Ende oder betrifft mich das gar nicht? Keine Ahnung, ich weiß gerade nicht mehr, wo ich stehe. Ich weiß nur irgendwie, dass ziemlich viel Geld jeden Monat von meinem Konto runtergeht, in irgendwelche Löcher verschwindet und dann ist es weg.
Also ich bin wirklich stinksauer. Ich drehe wirklich am Rad, wenn ich Kohl, so wie in Bremen sehe, großkotzige Sprüche loslassen oder die ganze versammelte Bande, was die im Augenblick von sich gibt, das macht mich so was von rasend, stink, sauer, wütend einfach.
Okay, also das heißt, wir sind wütend und wir wollen was dazu sagen.
Das wird nicht so bleiben, ich bin niemand, der sich wirklich leicht aufregt. Wenn ich mich bereits anfange aufzuregen, dann ist die Lage ernst.
Würdest du auf die Straße gehen, wegen der Geschichte?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich finde, die gehören erstmal alle in den Knast.
Kannst du nicht lieber die CDU-Page hacken oder was anderes drauf machen?
Die montieren sich ja schon selbst.
So gut kriegt das wirklich keiner hin.
Wie sie sich selber machen.
Wie sie sich im Moment ins Knie schießen wirklich ein. Das kann man so gut gar nicht hinkriegen.
Naja, das sagst du so, aber Kanzler Schröder sagt, er sieht die Demokratie nicht gefährdet.
Ja, ich meine, der Kanzler Schröder hat ja auch im Moment ein paar Dinge zu verantworten und im Rahmen dieses Verfahrens ist es ja so, dass beispielsweise der Herr Holzer, also einer der begünstigten von diesen 256 Millionen Mark, die Leuna gezahlt hat, sind ja 220 auf eines seiner Konten gemacht. Der Mann ist sogenannter Ex-BND-Mitarbeiter, also ehemaliger Mitarbeiter des Bundesnachrichtendienstes. Welche Tätigkeit er dort ausgeübt hat, unter welchem Zeitraum war immerhin letzte Woche im Spiegel noch Gegenstand von Andeutungen. Diese Woche ist im Spiegel zwar auch wieder zwei Seiten über Herrn Holzer, aber da wird der Bundesnachrichtendienst schon nicht mehr erwähnt. Andere Sachen, dass der Herr Pfahls, einer der Mitspieler hier, der jetzt mit internationalem Haftbefehl gesucht wird, der war ehemalige Präsident des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschützung. Wenn man sich ein bisschen mit diesen Behörden auseinandersetzt, dann weiß man niemand, der da mal Präsident war. Den lassen die sowieso ihr Leben lang nicht mehr aus den Augen, weil der Mann hat dann im Teil für Teil Kenntnis von Regierungsgeheimnissen und ist viel zu gefährlich, wenn er gekidnappt wird oder irgendwas. Also man hat ja schon den Eindruck, dass die Mächtigen, die jetzt sozusagen das Bruder haben, auch ihre...
Die sitzen im Glashaus mit drin.
Der Glashaus ist noch freundlich.
Ja, ich hab mich nun auch gefragt, warum Schröder nun so moderat auftritt plötzlich und alles, ob er sozusagen die Würde des Amtes wahren möchte, aber...
Also er heißt nach dem anderen, ich würde mal anfangen mit Fakten. Das ist mir alles noch...
Wir machen denke ich erstmal eine Runde Musik, dann fahren wir mal an uns nochmal kurz zu sortieren.
Fakten, Fakten, Fakten.
Wir haben auch ein bisschen was mitgebracht.
Nicht mehr an den Leser denken.
Okay, was soll ich jetzt auflegen? Wollt ihr den schon haben oder wollt ihr den haben? Gut, wir gehen dann natürlich auch irgendwann ans Telefon.
Na ja, später.
Sagt doch irgendwann 0331 70 97 110, könnt ihr ja schon mal merken, falls ihr es nicht im Speicher habt.
Und Mitglieder der CDU werden bevorzugt. Also wir machen nämlich hier eine Vorzensur.
Sowieso. Jetzt sag mal noch, welchen Track, Martin, da sind so viele.
Ich mag klar und undeutlich aussehen.
Der Blue Moon am Mittwochabend, der letzte Mittwoch im Monat, das ist wieder Chaosradio. Pavel, Martin und Andi sind da und sie haben das Thema CDU-Spendenaffäre, diesen ganzen großen Komplex sich ausgesucht unter dem Aspekt Verschwörungstheorie so ein bisschen.
Naja, oder auch unter dem Aspekt des Betriebssystems Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Und bevor wir da jetzt sozusagen in die Details gehen, haben wir uns überlegt, wollen wir erstmal versuchen, das große Bild zu malen. Das große Bild besteht ja im Moment bei dem, womit sich die Presse beschäftigt aus. Da gibt es so wie große Geldmengen, die von Waffenhändlern oder von ausländischen Mineralölkonzernen oder von wem auch immer an Parteien gespendet werden. Und diese Parteien, also warum auch immer diese Beträge fließen, man könnte ja auch auf die Idee kommen, und das ist ja sicherlich auch Gegenstand der öffentlichen Betrachtung, wurden damit irgendwelche politischen Entscheidungen begünstigt usw. Und diese Gelder sind eben nicht ordnungsgemäß deklariert worden. Das ist irgendwie die juristische Komponente, was aber im Moment noch gar nicht richtig gefragt wurde, ist, wo sind dann die Gelder hingegangen? Weil da fielen ja auch ganz erhebliche Beträge.
Ich meine, es sind ja im Prinzip Gelder aufgetaucht und verschwunden. Also und es wurden ja immer mehr, vielleicht doch noch mal chronologisch. Ich meine, angefangen hat das Ganze ja mit dem Leisler Kieb Koffer, mit der Million, die da irgendwann übergeben wurde, im Rahmen mit der saudiarabischen Panzeraffäre. Und dann ja, dann tauchte, wenn ich das richtig sehe, genau, dann... Ja, Leuna kam ja immer zwischendurch mal wieder hoch, aber noch so richtig klar ist, ist das ja nicht ach so genau. Dann kam Kohl mit seinen zwei Millionen, so die er dann zugegeben hat, geschickterweise in den Zeitraum seit 1984, 94, so im Zeitraum seit 94. Dann kam plötzlich die Hessen Bombe, wo plötzlich 16 Millionen aufgetaucht sind, von denen vier Millionen aber verschwunden sind. Das war ja richtig, richtig schön. Und naja, nun der letzte Stand war ja, dass jetzt nochmal 12 Millionen bei der Bundespartei aufgetaucht sind. Ich meine, man verliert wirklich langsam den Überblick, wenn man das nicht alles mitschreibt, was da jeden Tag über die Sender kommt.
Das Problem ist ja, dass nichts mitgeschrieben wurde. Also das Interessante an dem Geld ist ja nicht nur irgendwie, dass es reingekommen ist von der Industrie und dass es rausgegangen ist an irgendwelche Parteiverbände, vielleicht für den Wahlkampf oder so, sondern das Interessante ist, dass dieses Geld über schwarze Kassen geflossen ist für die schwarze Partei. Also die haben ja schwarze Kassen und dass es halt eben reingekommen ist in Koffern und rausgegangen ist in Koffern, dass also Barübergabe das bevorzugte Medium war, um dieses Geld zu transferieren, wie man so sagt, in der Kommunikation.
Deswegen hat ja die Wirtschaftsprüfungsinstitution, diese Ernst- und Young Leute bei der CDU gegenüber Frau Merkel von einem Geldwäsche ähnlichen System geredet, weil es da nicht nur darum geht, dass da Geld irgendwie hingekommen ist, sondern dass es auch wieder rausgegangen ist und dass die CDU so gesehen nur so eine Waschanlage war, wo also irgendwie Gelder dubiosester Herkunft und dubiosesten Zielorts durchgelaufen sind.
Das stand noch an der Elftankstelle vorhin?
Ja, genau, also vorhin auf dem Weg hier hin musste ich irgendwie tanken und meine Nachbarin, die da noch im Auto saß, zeigte, dass das Wort Elftankstelle jetzt auch eine ganz andere Bedeutung bekommt. Und die Frage aber bei diesen Beträgen, die Elft da ausgegeben hat, also 256 Millionen Mark, was ja auch nach seriöser Einschätzung weit über dem Wert eigentlich liegt, den man da bekommt, da gibt es jetzt mittlerweile auch Recherchen, die in die Richtung gehen, ob nicht sozusagen Kohl dem Mitterand, da mehr oder weniger, nee, Chirac war das noch, oder war das, nee, das war noch Mitterand, das war noch Mitterand, dem ein mehr oder weniger persönlich strategisch-militärischen Gefallen getan hat, frei nach dem Motto, ein Tankstellnetz ist auch im Falle eines Krieges eine wichtige Infrastrukturmaßnahme und es könnte auch sozusagen dem Sicherheitsbedürfnis der Franzosen ein entgegenkommen gewesen sein, wo dann einfach also der Goodwill der französischen Regierung auf so eine Art und Weise eingefädelt wurde, was zugegebenerweise erstmal für normalen Bürger fernabjäglicher Realitäten ist, aber die Frage ist ja auch, nehmen wir mal an, die hohe Politik funktioniert so, wer muss denn da eigentlich alles noch eine Mark abbekommen, damit sowas funktioniert? Und jetzt haben wir hier schon wieder die Nachrichten, vielleicht bringen die auch neue Erkenntnis in dieser Sache. Hast du mal einen Nachrichtenshingel da von der Moderatorin?
Konsequenz. Nordrhein-Westfalens Finanzminister Schleuser, SPD, ist zurückgetreten. Er zog damit die Konsequenz aus der sogenannten Flugaffäre. Schleuser musste einräumen, dass er auf zwei von der Westdeutschen Landesbank bezahlten Dienstflüge seine Freunde mitgenommen hatte. Ministerpräsident Kliment äußerte Verständnis für den Schritt. Rotstift. Rund 20.000 Menschen haben heute vor dem Landtag in Potsdam gegen die geplanten Streichungen im Kita-Bereich protestiert. Die Brandenburger Koalition will die Zuschüsse für Kindertagesstätten in diesem und im nächsten Jahr um 93 Millionen Mark kürzen. Appell. Bundeskanzler Schröder hat auf der Internationalen Holocaust-Konferenz in Stockholm zu einer stärkeren Zusammenarbeit gegen Neonazis aufgerufen. Dazu gehöre die geistige Auseinandersetzung mit dem Rassismus, sagte er. Schröder äußerte sich auch besorgt über eine mögliche Regierungsbeteiligung der rechtsgerichteten FPÖ in Österreich. Vorwurf. Die Hilfsorganisation für politische Opfer, HELP, hat gegen den Regisseur des Films Sonnenallee, Leander Hausmann, Strafanzeige gestellt. Die wirft ihm Beleidigung der Maueropfer vor. Sonnenallee war mit über zwei Millionen Kinobesuchern der erfolgreichste deutsche Spielfilm im vergangenen Jahr.
Sport.
Basketball in der Bundesliga hat Alba gegen Braunschweig mit 85 zu 61 gewonnen. Alba bleibt damit an der Tabellenspitze.
Wetter.
Nachts zeitweise Regen 1 bis 3 Grad am Tag, ebenfalls leichter Regen 2 bis 5 Grad.
Kein Verkehr?
Nein.
Kein Verkehr? Heute mit Chaos Radio, Andi ist da, Pavel ist da, Martin ist gerade nicht da. Neuerkenntnisse aus dem Info? Nö, eigentlich nicht, außer dass Schleusser zurückgetreten ist zum Thema.
Aber ich glaube wir wollten jetzt erst mal die Musik hören, dann sortieren wir hier mal kurz unsere Verschwörungstheorien, die wir uns jetzt gleich widmen.
Gut, machen wir.
Oder was ist italienische Volksmusik? Also der Schleuser ist zurückgetreten, finde ich cool, der Mann ist konsequent. Der ist der einzige, der irgendwie, naja wie lange hat er gebraucht? Zwei Wochen oder so, relativ kurz?
Erstmal alles verschwiegen und zwar mit der Begründung, er wollte auf die Privatsphäre der Frau, mit der seine Ehefrau betrogen hat, Rücksicht nehmen oder irgendwie so.
Na ja, aber ich meine, überleg mal von der CDU, wer da hätte schon alles zurücktreten können, wenn er denn gewollt worden hätte. Ich finde es interessant, dass von der SPD im Ausland nicht die Rede war. Ich war jetzt gerade irgendwie für ein paar Tage im Ausland und in den Zeitungen habe ich eigentlich nur über die CDU gelesen und jetzt tritt einer von der SPD zurück und die CDU versucht nach wie vor, die Schuldigen zu finden und sie dann auszumerzen. Also es ist ja so, bei der CDU sind ja nicht alle 630.000 Partei-Mitglieder schuld, sondern die meisten CDU-Mitglieder, also nicht nur Wähler, tun wirklich was für die Partei, setzten sich ein für Ziele, konservativ oder rechtsstaatlich oder fortschrittlich.
Die haben ein Problem und das Problem heißt Kohle. Die haben irgendwie eine Integrationsfigur, einen etwas zu langen Zeitraum gehabt.
Ja, aber alle sagen jetzt, Kohle ist schuld, dabei stimmt das überhaupt nicht. Kohle ist überhaupt nicht schuld. Der Mann hat was getan für den Staat und alle anderen tun auch was für den Staat. Und die ganze Partei funktioniert nur dadurch, dass sie etwas für den Staat tun können und dafür brauchen sie verdammt noch mal Geld. Wenn die ihre Waschanlage nicht hätten, dann könnten sie das gar nicht tun, was sie tun.
Naja, das sehe ich ein bisschen anders.
Also, ich meine, sie könnten die Waschanlage ja öffentlich betreiben. So, und sehen, wer da die Münzen reinsteckt und wer da reinfährt und was daraus kommt.
Wenn die Waschanlage dann nicht mehr funktionieren würde, dann müssten sie Steuern zahlen.
Also mir fällt da dieses geflügelte Wort von diesem Waffenhändler Schreiber ein, der ja gesagt hat, diese 100.000 Mark an Herrn Schäuble, wenn sie es so wollen, nennen sie es Landschaftspflege. Und diesen Begriff der Landschaftspflege, den finde ich da sehr deutlich. Ich meine, wenn Waffenhändler christliche Parteien pflegen, was sind dann eigentlich diejenigen, die im Zweifelsfall andere Parteien pflegen?
Auch Waffenhändler, die Waffenhändler müssen immer die Partei pflegen, die an der Macht ist.
Ja gut, aber dann, wenn du sagst, die müssen das tun, dann sollten wir vielleicht doch als Konsequenz die Institutionen abschaffen, oder was wäre die Alternative?
Waffenhändler ja, würde ich echt gerne abschaffen.
Ja gut, aber das wird ein bisschen schwierig, ne? Ich meine, Waffenhändler sind ja auch praktisch, die haben offenbar praktische Verbindungen. Wenn dann Leute zu viel wissen, dann begehen sie auf einmal Selbstmord oder so. Ich meine, es gibt ja im Zusammenhang, wenn man sozusagen versucht, den groben Plot zu nehmen und das System Kohl, hast du auch noch Literatur mitgebracht von Herrn Brauchitsch, der Preis des Schweigens.
Ich möchte nämlich da an der Stelle halt mal einhaken. Es ist einfach nicht sinnvoll, Politiker zu suchen, die jetzt schuld waren, an irgendetwas diese Politiker rauszuschmeißen. Weil der Herr von Brauchitsch hat in seinem Buch Der Preis des Schweigens mal so ein bisschen erzählt, warum er geschwiegen hat. Also er hat ja sozusagen gerade das durchgemacht, was dem Herrn Kohl bevorsteht. Ein 15-jähriges Martyrium und dann schreibt Kohl vielleicht irgendwann auch noch ein Buch. Herr von Brauchitsch, darf ich zitieren, sagt Die Zuwendungen an die Parteien waren in diesem Sinne keine Spenden. Weder die Friedrich-Flicke-KG, noch irgendein anderes der mir bekannten großen Unternehmen hätte aus freien Stücken einer politischen Partei Geld zukommen lassen. Bei den Zuwendungen an die Parteien handelt es hier vielmehr um Schutzgelder. Die sogenannte Spendenaffäre war in Wahrheit eine Schutzgelderaffäre. Und weiter unten sagt er Die Zahlung erfolgte nicht, weil wir den Eindruck hatten, uns auf diese Weise die Vertreter der Politik dienstbar machen zu können. Sie erfolgten, weil wir andernfalls in die Isolation geraten wären. Nach einem Schlüssel, den die Parteien festlegten, wurden die einzelnen Branchen und innerhalb dieser Branchen die einzelnen Unternehmen zur Kasse gebeten. Wer viel erwirtschaftet hat, musste folglich viel zahlen. Parteispenden waren nichts anderes als eine Form der indirekten Steuern. Das heißt, dass es ein ausgeklügeltes System gibt, wie sich die Parteien, egal welche dran ist, an der Macht halten.
Interessant, wenn man das jetzt so hört. Wie heißt der Paragraf noch mit der Gründung einer kriminellen Vereinigung?
129a.
129a. Aber da ist es ja so, dass Parteien ausdrücklich ausgeschlossen sind von diesen Paragrafen. Es wird extra eine Ausnahme gemacht.
Was man machen könnte, wäre ja eine Personengruppe innerhalb der CDU als 129a zu machen. Ich habe vor ein paar Tagen mir noch mal die Plenardebatten über den Großen Lauschangriff reingezogen und zu meinem Amesimor festgestellt, dass der ausgerechnet Herr Kanter war, der den Bereich der Geldwäschedelikte mit in den Straftatenkatalog des Großen Lauschangriffs mit eingebracht hat. Also der Saubermann Kanter wäre ja eigentlich jetzt ein potenzieller Kandidat oder auch Herr Kohl. Wenn dann die Namen der Spender nicht preisgeben würden, dann muss man vielleicht seine Wohnung mit einem entsprechenden Lauschangriff, für den er auch eingesetzt hat.
Na, da gibt es ja noch die Gaukakten, wo die Stasia noch alles mit ausgespeichert hat, habe ich jetzt heute zufällig.
Aber die Frage besteht überhaupt ein Interesse daran, diese Gaukakten denn tatsächlich?
Die Parteien haben kein Interesse, dass irgendwie rauskommt, was läuft.
Aber was meint er denn mit Schutzgelderpressung? Die Parteien erpressen also die Unternehmer?
Ja.
Und was sind die Konsequenzen, wenn sie nicht zahlen?
Dass die Branche bzw. das Unternehmen in unserer Industrie und in unserer Wirtschaft weniger Chancen hat.
Naja, ich meine, ich glaube nicht, dass man wirklich...
Ich dachte, vielleicht kann man mal diesen Apparat mal ausmachen.
Ja, gut, die Trennung zwischen Parteien und Firmen, die er da nun propagiert, also, ich meine, gut brauche ich... Es ist, glaube ich, ziemlich verbittert.
Nee, nee, der Mann ist gut. Ich habe da heute quer gelesen, sein Buch, das ist klasse, es liest sich toll. Der Preis des Schweigens liest sich wie der Spiegel. Man hat das auch innerhalb von einem Tag durch. Der Mann schreibt gut und der Mann hat recht. Der Mann beschreibt einfach, wie es läuft.
Na, seine Sicht der Dinge. Also ich kaufe ihm das nun alles nicht unbedingt.
Auch der Schreiber sagt ja im Moment, wie es läuft. Der Schreiber hat ja auch eine gewisse Beruhigung, wenn man dann so Sätze liest wie, dass er CDU-Chef Wolfgang Schäuble als hinterhältigen Lügner den bayerischen Regierungschef Edmund Stoiber schlicht als Arschloch bezeichnet. Ich meine, gut, das sind klare Worte, aber ob der Mann jetzt hier nur die Wahrheit sagt und die reine Wahrheit oder doch eher seine Version der Wahrheit. Also die Frage ist, gibt es in so einem Spiel die Wahrheit?
Na die Wahrheit, die Wahrheit.
Also das ist jetzt eine sehr schwere Frage. Ich würde gerne mal auf das zurückkommen, was ihr am Anfang gesagt habt, das Betriebssystem. Wenn die Verfassung und das Grundgesetz das Betriebssystem ist, wo ist dann, wo seht ihr dann, wo macht ihr den Ansatz mit den Verstreckungen zwischen Politik, Kapital, Industrie, Militär und Geheimdiensten? Spielt das überhaupt eine Rolle das Betriebssystem oder haben die ihr eigenes Betriebssystem laufen?
Der Herr von Brauchitsch hat...
Abseits von dem, was wir glauben, dass das Betriebssystem sei. Das ist doch die Frage.
Der Herr von Brauchitsch hat einen Zusammenhang geschildert mit einer These. Er hat gesagt, die Parteien und die Industrie können nur in Deutschland koexistieren. Wenn es die Industrie in der Form, wenn es diese Verknüpfung nicht gibt, dann haben die Parteien kein Geld. Und wenn die Parteien kein Geld haben, das ist meine Theorie, dann haben sie keine Geld, kein Geld genug Werbung zu machen und genug Menschen in Deutschland für sich zu begeistern. Das heißt, es gibt dann keine großen Volksparteien.
Ja gut, aber um noch mal ganz kurz auf die Frage zurückzukommen, wo ist der Bug im Betriebssystem? Ich meine, das ist ja, dass die Parteien sozusagen darauf...
Nein, das funktioniert.
Nein, das Problem ist, dass das Betriebssystem oder das, was da an Anwendungen oben draufläuft, alles doch, ja, heute würde man es als Legacy, als Hinterlassenschaft bezeichnen von über 40 Jahren kalten Krieg. Und davor wuselt da auch noch einiges rum. Und ich meine, die sind halt so die Politik und die Unternehmen natürlich Hand in Hand, die mehr oder weniger dieses Land irgendwie wieder hingebaut sind.
Aber wir können uns ja mal, wenn wir uns andere Länder angucken. Also die Amerikaner zum Beispiel, die haben ja keinen Datenschutz. Darüber regen sich Deutsche gerne auf. Weil wenn du Kunde eines amerikanischen Unternehmens als Deutscher wirst, hast du all das, was du an Datenschutz gewohnt hast, gibt es dann nicht. Was die Amerikaner anstelle dessen haben und weswegen die dieses europäische Bedürfnis mitunter auch nicht verstehen, ist ja der Freedom of Information Act. Und das ist etwas, was aus unserer Verfassung abgeleitet leider nicht existiert, nämlich ein Recht des Bürgers, die ihnen betreffenden Dinge und überhaupt die sogenannten Staatsgeheimnisse nach einer angemessenen Zeit von 15 Jahren einsehen zu können. Da wird gnadenlos offen gelegt, was vor 15 Jahren gelaufen ist. Jetzt kann man sagen, okay, 15 Jahre ist ganz schön heavy, aber auch davor hat zumindest jeder Bürger das Recht, die über ihn gespeicherten Dinge in Erfahrung zu bringen. Und was wir haben, beispielsweise mit dem Bundesnachrichtendienst, der ja eigentlich eine amerikanische Tochter ist, Fremde Heere Ost, Herr Gehlen und so weiter und so fort, ist ja eine Institution, wo wir eben keine solche Rechtsgrundlage haben, wo wir nicht wissen, wie es ist, und wo man den Eindruck hat, in diesem aktuellen Skandal beispielsweise, dass das historisch einfach eins zu eins durchläuft. Dass wir hier an Parteien kann da wechseln, was will. Und das sehe ich als echten Bug an, dass wir da so Institutionen haben, in die wir als Büros...
Du siehst das vielleicht als Bug, was ich die ganze Zeit sage, ist, dass Betriebssystem Bundesrepublik Deutschland funktioniert. Es ist ein Betriebssystem, das wurde 1949 geschaffen und wurde seitdem aufgebohrt.
Ja, und zwar besteht es, wenn man mal die Systemressourcen sich anschaut, so roundabout 80 Millionen Menschen, von denen 60, 70 Millionen vielleicht wahlberechtigt sind. Und zwei Millionen von denen sind in politischen Parteien, das sind sozusagen schon so etwas subalterne Machtknoten. Dann gibt es, ich glaube, 70.000 Funktionäre rund in Deutschland, die irgendwie tatsächlich noch ein bisschen mehr umsetzen. Und gieblich etwa um die 2.000 Personen, die tatsächlich das eigentliche Scheduling und die eigentliche Ressourcenverteilung machen. Also ich denke, in diesem Kreis ungefähr der 2.000, das sind diejenigen, die vermutlich mehr zu sagen haben als die restlichen 80 Millionen ungefähr. Das ist so vielleicht mal eine etwas quantifizierte Sicht.
Und was für eine Rolle spielen die in den Betriebssystemen?
Naja, wer fällt dann die Entscheidung und warum? Nehmen wir mal jetzt Leuna an. Da könnte man sagen, deutsche Arbeitsplätze und dies und das. Da könnte dann eine Entscheidung in die eine Richtung fällen und die vielen Leute, die brav ihre CDU und der SPD...
Also bei Leuten waren das ein paar Leute, die die Entscheidung gefällt haben.
Die haben sich sicherlich nicht um die anderen interessiert, die zu den zwei Millionen gehören, die Mitglied in politischen Parteien betreffen und denken, dass sie dadurch etwas bewirken oder auch nur für ihr Land was tun.
Da ist die Frage einfach, warum bekommt 11 Leuna und die Antwort, die kannst du irgendwie hinreichend verschwörungstheoretisch begründen. Irgendwas davon wird schon stimmen.
Also bei dem großen Bild kannst du sagen, es ist wie eine Matrix oder so. Es ist wie Virtual PC für Mac. Vorne läuft der PC, das ist das Grundgesetz, und hinten läuft das wahre Betriebssystem. Und das ist halt, wenn man es jetzt wirklich ganz schwarz-weiß sehen will, das ist die Vereinbarung zwischen der Partei, zwischen der CDU und der Wirtschaft. Es ist diese Übereinkunft, wie es zu laufen hat. Die Parteien werden über die Spenden finanziert, und dafür werden industriefreundliche Entscheidungen gefällt.
Genau, und das, was gerade im Moment passiert, ist sozusagen ein Bug in der Matrix. Also genauso wie die schwarze Katze, die auf einmal zweimal durchläuft, irgendwie passieren im Moment so ein paar Dinge, die sich der Normalbürger nicht mehr erklären kann. Da gibt es da natürlich Erklärungen, die gereicht werden. Also ich nehme jetzt zum Beispiel mal den angeblichen Selbstmord oder sagen wir neutral mal den Tod des für die CDU-Fraktion verantwortlichen Finanzleiters dort, der ja ganz überraschend persönliche Probleme hatte, von denen weder seine Familie noch seinen Pfarrer noch sonst jemand wusste, und dann sich eben Tod aufgefunden hat. Dann tauchen zwei Abschiedsbriefe von ihm auf, die zunächst einmal verdeckt gehalten werden, warum auch immer. Und der Familie wird in der Obduktion verweigert. Es ist natürlich offensichtlicher Selbstmord. Und der Normalbürger kommt auch überhaupt nicht auf die Idee zu fragen, also wenn man Bilanschen mit mehreren Millionensstellensummen irgendwie fälschen kann, dann kann man auch ganz bestimmt keine Abschiedsbriefe fälschen. Das ist natürlich, also ich finde, das ist anlässlich schon eine Dreissigkeit. Und das meine ich mit Wack in der Matrix. Also normalerweise funktioniert das mit dem Virtual PC und dem Hintergrundprogramm so ein bisschen dezent. Wir haben irgendwie so, wir können uns vorstellen, ja irgendwie die Leuna und die Franzose.
Wir müssen ja irgendwie mal das Betriebssystem.
Ja und die Frage ist, wollen wir das noch so? Also ich finde, es stinkt so.
Ich will Windows, ich will das Betriebssystem nicht mehr sehen.
Nee, als F4.
Nee, ich brauch so eine Oberfläche von Bill Gates irgendwie und da muss ein Browser drauf sein und dann bin ich drin.
Ja, aber die Frage ist doch niemal im Ernst. Auch andere Sachen jetzt. Hier diese Akten, die Leuna Akten, die ja tatsächlich spannend sind, weil die ja nicht nur aus irgendeinem Archiv oder aus irgendeiner Registratur verschwunden sind, sondern das ist die bestgesicherste Aktenablage dieser Republik. So, da kriegst du die Akten nur ausgeliehen, du musst vorher unterschreiben, das wird in Listen eingetragen, es muss abends wieder eingeheftet werden. Dieser Raum, in dem die Akten sind, das sind also Stahltüren usw. Dieser Raum ist konstruiert nach den Vorgaben des Bundesamts für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik. Der Geheimschutzbeauftragte des Bundeskanzleramts ist zufällig ehemaliger BND-Mitarbeiter. Irgendwo muss er seine Kompetenzen hier haben. Dass die Akten verschwunden sind, da kann man auch die Frage stellen. Sind die alle korrupt? Oder ist es so, dass die Mächtigen sich für den Fall, dass ihnen dieser Skript, diese Grundgesetzgeschichte, dass die ihnen gerade nicht in den Koffer passt, halten die sich nicht da irgendwelche Backdoors? Halten sich die da irgendwelche Hintertüren? Ich glaube, es sind Hintertüren. Genauso wie wir in den Windows- oder in den Firewall-Geschichten haben wir immer diese kleinen latenten Geheimdienstmöglichkeiten, um dann doch reinzukommen, wo dann auch mal Hacker reinfallen und sonst was von komischen Dingen passieren. Aber ich glaube, genauso wie sich so ein Firewall-Hersteller irgendwie seine Hintertür hält für den Fall, dass seine Regierung mal ran will, hält sich die Bundesregierung in diesem ganzen Gesetzkonglomerat auch so die Hintertüren.
Das brauchst du, sonst kannst du das System nicht administrieren. Die Bundesregierung braucht einen Adminzugang, da braucht sie alle Rechte.
Ich glaube, ich habe ein tolles Fremdwort, was das Ganze beschreibt, woran die vermutlich leiden, nämlich kollektive kognitive Dissonanz. Dann erläutern Sie mal, ja. Wahrnehmungsstörungen bzw. sehen sie halt das, was sie sehen wollen und das ihr Wertesystem. Sie bewerten die Dinge nicht, wie sie kommen, sondern sie schaffen ihre Werte nach den Fakten.
Die Politiker sind doch gutgläubig. Die glauben doch irgendwie an das System.
Bei Kohl beispielsweise.
Viele sind gerade erschrocken, auch viele Parteimitglieder.
Bei Kohl kann ich mir die Gleichung, die da funktioniert, in seinem Kopf kann ich mir durchaus noch fast vorstellen, oder damals funktioniert hat. Also damals war es ja so, Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat da halt gleichgesetzt mit der Bundesregierung natürlich und die Bundesregierung gleichgesetzt natürlich mit der Regierungspartei, seiner Partei, der CDU und die hat da wiederum gleichgesetzt mit sich selbst. Und wenn er also Geld von irgendjemand genommen hat, dann war das halt Geld für Deutschland. So, und das konnte vermutlich nur gut gewesen sein.
Darf ich ja mal in die Bibel ein bisschen...
Aber das erinnert mich doch ganz stark an Honecker, der wahrscheinlich auch bis zuletzt geglaubt hat.
Das ist ja eine andere Frage. Mach mal nicht den Trichter.
Ich hab neulich in einem Leserbrief in der Sonntag Aktuell-Zeitung ein Bibelzitat gelesen. Der Autor des Leserbriefs hat gesagt, er wundert sich überhaupt nicht, die Christlich Demokratische Union hat doch nur das gemacht, was in der Bibel steht. Weil in der Bibel steht im Lukas 16, Vers 9, machet euch Freunde mit dem ungerechten Mammon, auf das, wenn ihr nun darbelt, sie euch aufnehmen in die ewigen Hütten. So, so.
Du meinst, es ging dem Kohl nur um den Zugang zu den ewigen Hütten.
Er setzt sich erstmal zacken lassen bei etwas Musik.
Also das ist harter Tobak.
Guten Abend allerseits. Im Studio bei Chaos Radio sind Pavel, Martin, Andi und ich bin Sabine. Wir machen gleich die Telefonen auf. Ich sag schon mal die Nummer 0331 70 97 110.
Ja, macht euch Freunde steht in der Bibel. Macht euch Freunde mit dem ungerechten Mammon. Der Schreiber nennt das Landschaftspflege. Schon in der Bibel steht irgendwie macht euch Freunde mit den Waffenhändlern und mit allen Leuten, die Geld haben. Und da wurde natürlich mal in der Zeitung ein Tübinger Professor für christliche Sozialethik befragt, was denn nun die Kirchen dazu meinen. Also die Frage direkt an ihn war, die Kirchen sind ein Teil der Gesellschaft und nehmen für sich in Anspruch auf Missstände aufmerksam zu machen. Warum melden sich die Kirchenvertreter in dieser Angelegenheit, wenn überhaupt nur sehr zurückhaltend zu Wort und der Professor für Sozialethik sagt, das wüsste ich auch gerne einmal. Die Kirchen hätten sich längst deutlich äußern müssen, denn es ist ihre Aufgabe, bei der Klärung zu helfen. Nun frage ich mich natürlich selbst, warum melden sich die Kirchen eigentlich überhaupt nicht?
Die Kirchen haben sich gemeldet. Alle zusammen sogar. Also sie haben das kritisiert.
Außer Coles Privatpriester, ich weiß nicht, wie er heißt, der meinte, Coles müsste unbedingt sein Ehrenwort halten, was er einmal gegeben hat und der war glaube ich irgendwie schon 120 Jahre alt.
Ich schätze mal, dass der Herr Coles bestimmt auch ein paar Rosenkränze gebildet hat in letzter Zeit für seine Sünden.
Also ich glaube, dass der Mann mehr macht als Rosenkränze bilden. Der macht sich lustig.
Über alle Idioten, die jetzt rumlaufen über irgendwie seine Partei, wo nicht irgendwie einer drin ist, der mal ein bisschen Arsch in der Hose hat.
Das macht den armen Coles nicht so fertig.
Ich finde, die hätten ihn gleich am Anfang rauskanten sollen, achtkantig und irgendwie dann meinetwegen in den offenen Vollzug mit Grenz zusammen. Oder irgendwo soll er, weiß ich nicht, nach Chile oder sonst wo.
Glaubst du, dass die Parteien ernsthaft daran interessiert sind, dass der Herr Coles irgendetwas aussagt? Meine Antwort lautet nein, sie sind nicht daran interessiert. Sie sind sogar eher daran interessiert, dass der Hokeol schweigt.
Also ich glaube auch eher, dass sie da eher so ein Schalk-Goldowski-Problem haben, den sie ja auch nicht in aller Härte verfolgt haben, sondern dem sie irgendwie ein nettes Leben beschert haben, dafür, dass da eben über das Privatleben westdeutscher Politiker nicht zu laut redet.
Nur so wie sie es jetzt anfangen, schaffen sie es wirklich, die gesamte Partei wie in Italien in Grund und Boden zu fahren. Da wird in einem Jahr, wenn es so weitergeht, nicht viel mehr von übrig sein.
Das geht doch gar nicht mehr um die CDU.
Die Frage, die wir jetzt auch an die Hörer stellen können, ist ja, ist das gut so, weil die Partei in den Boden fahren? Oder andererseits, ich meine, wir haben ja auch schon öfter darüber diskutiert, halb im Spaß, aber zunehmend auch mit seriösen, bei guten Argumenten, ob wir nicht als CCC-Partei werden, also die CCCP, da gibt es ja auch noch jede Menge Logos.
Da müssen wir erst mal unsere Finanzen klären.
Ja genau, aber dann, ich meine, wenn man Partei ist, dann ist das mit den Männern, mit den Geldkoffern und so, dann macht man alles etwas ein, dann kommen keine mehr an die Tür, wenn du in den Parteien bist.
Im Augenblick, habe ich gelesen, gibt es ja auch einen regelrechten Spendenstau, also die großen Unternehmen sind völlig verunsichert, wissen nicht mehr, wohin mit ihren Spenden.
Wir nehmen im Moment auch keine Spenden mehr.
Es gibt ja was für den Strom irgendwie, Anni, wie sieht es denn aus?
Na ja, unsere Stromrechte wird es jeden Monat durchgeben.
Ja, wenn ihr spenden wollt, müsst ihr erst mal euren...
Postbank, Berlin, es ist auch ganz egal, wo das Geld herkommt...
.euren Verfassungspatriotismus ablegen, wenn ihr Spenden entgegennehmen wollt.
Verfassungspatriotismus, was ist denn das jetzt, liebe Moderatorin?
Das ist ein Patriotismus, der nicht auf diesem Vaterlandsgedanken basiert, sondern der einfach eine Verfassungstreue ist. Du bist also ein Patriot, der nicht nationalistisch denkt, sondern ein Patriot im Sinne der Verfasser.
Aber es scheint mir doch, dass mit diesem Verfassungspatriotismus frei nach keiner Ahnung, wem vorgegangen wird. Also nach dieser berühmten Aussage, was schert mich mein Gesabbel von gestern, um nicht zu sagen, es ist doch da kaum jemand anzutreffen, der da tatsächlich sich noch drauf beruft, oder?
Ich hatte so das Gefühl, dass ihr euch ein bisschen drauf beruft.
Wir stellen ja eher die Frage, ob das Problem nicht schon in der Verfassung ist, weil wenn man die Verfassungstreue ablegen kann und sie danach ignoriert, dann ist das offenbar nicht viel wert.
Ja Moment, da ist aber nicht die Verfassung schuld, sondern da sind die Institutionen schuld, die auf die Verfassung aufpassen sollten. Die müssen darauf achten, dass die Verfassung eingehalten wird. Moment, Moment, der Bundespräsident kann im Moment keinen Piep sagen. Ich hab den überhaupt nicht mehr gesehen seit Wochen. Gibt's den eigentlich noch? Oder ist das schon eine Holografie oder so? Ja, der ist verschwunden, weil er kann nichts sagen, weil er zu viel mit dem Flieger rumgeflogen ist. Wobei ich das mit dem Flieger rumfliegen mit seinen Geliebten finde ich wesentlich weniger schlimm. Das ist einfach eine ganz primitive Inanspruchnahme von gewissen Politikerprivilegen. Das finde ich viel weniger schlimm, als Millionen von schwarzen Geldern irgendwie aufzuheufen und damit so ein System zu etablieren, was die Verfassung wirklich lächerlich macht.
Meinst du, es gibt mehr oder weniger schlimm? Also soll man diskutieren, was ist schlimmer? 100 Millionen von da oder 50 Millionen von da?
Wir brauchen darüber nicht zu diskutieren. Ich habe es einfach mal so gesagt.
In den USA gibt es übrigens dafür die Air Force Two. Also das ist das Flugzeug des Vizepräsidenten, wo halt dann die verdienten Leute mit ihren Geliebten rumfliegen können.
Aber ich möchte diese Form der Korruption unbedingt unterstützen, weil auch die Sache mit Lewinsky, wo sich Clinton hat, vor seinem Treffen mit Arafat noch einen blasen lassen. Also ich meine, es ist uns doch wesentlich lieber, wenn ein amerikanischer Präsident entspannt in so einem Gespräch in einer kritischen Situation geht, als wenn er irgendwie mit seinem Hormonstau gleichzeitig nicht zu kämpfen hat und dann noch mit Palästinensern und wie sie alle heißen.
Ja, oder liest mal den Spiegelartikel diese Woche über, jetzt habe ich den Namen vergessen, ein kubanischer Autor, der wirklich in der Riege der der vordersten Machtmenschen war auf Kuba. Da hatte jeder zwei Frauen, zwei Wohnungen, tolle Autos, was weiß ich, eine Ray-Band, Sonnenbrille und Levi's, während die anderen das natürlich alle nicht hatten. Also so richtig kindlich, so ganz naiv, Privilegien einfach für sich in Anspruch nehmen. Ich meine, das ist doch irgendwie nachvollziehbar.
Ja, nachvollziehbar ist es, aber die Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, wenn du sagst, die Verfassung ist in Ordnung, und nur die Leute, die den Verfassungsschul absetzen, sind das Problem. Das klingt für mich so ein bisschen wie die Sozialismustheorie. Das ist irgendwie eine Primateorie, aber irgendwie fehlen uns da noch die richtigen Menschen für.
Ich meine, vielleicht erleben wir ja jetzt genau das, was mir so vor zehn Jahren in den Sinn kam, als der Sozialismus erledigt war, oder sich selbst erledigt hat. Die Frage, wie lange wird es noch dauern, bis sich irgendwie das andere System, was sich doch stark gestützt hat, irgendwie auch zerlegt, um dann irgendetwas Neues sich zu transformieren. Und so langsam bekomme ich den Eindruck, dass das jetzt gerade stattfindet.
Ange, sag doch mal die Fragen an die Hörer.
Die Frage an die Hörer ist ganz einfach. Was lehrt uns das?
Nein, wie geht es weiter?
Und was ist die Antwort auf alle Fragen?
Wir hören dich.
Ach naja, das übliche. Hallo, wer ist da? Hallo, Ricardo.
Ja, wir hören dich. Wunderbar.
Wieso? Bist du das noch nicht leid? Also eigentlich hätte man doch denken können, dass das nach zwei Wochen das Thema völlig out ist.
Nee, ich bin ganz froh darüber. Ich hoffe, dass es nicht so ganz in Richtung Verschwörungstheorie wie vor 14 Tagen abdriften wird. Also dass da ein bisschen sachlicher darüber geredet wird.
Gab es hier vor 14 Tagen schon mal eine Sendung dazu?
Ach, es gab vor 14 Tagen irgendwie nicht zu dem Thema, sondern über Verschwörungstheorien, Mystizismus und so ein Spuk halt, Spöken-Gigerei halt eine Sendung dazu. Das war ziemlich ätzend. Ja, was ich meine.
Ja, wie geht es weiter?
Wie geht es weiter?
Naja eben, es soll ganz sicher offenbar, Kanzler Schröder weiß es offenbar nicht, Herr Schäuble weiß es offenbar auch nicht. Also wer soll es wissen, wenn nicht wir als...
Unsere Hörer. Also es sollen wir jetzt die anrufen, die es wissen.
Ja, aber die Frage, die du sie gestellt hast, geht so nicht zu stellen, weil es doch schon sehr, sage ich mal, rezeptartig, wonach du fragst.
Nee, mehr so, das ist schon mehr so eine persönliche Einschätzung, Wünsche, oder...
Also ich befürchte, das geht immer stärker alles in den Bach runter. Die Repression wird zunehmen, die Armut wird wachsen und die Konflikte auch.
Oh Gott, ich glaube, du hast heute ein Spiegel gelesen oder sowas. Die ganze Welt ist scheiße.
Ich lese ein Spiegel selten.
Ja, da wird man noch was so depressiv hinterher kommen.
Nee, also es ist einfach, ja ich weiß nicht, zum Beispiel mich würde interessieren, vielleicht weiß das jemand von euch, wie groß die DG gewesen ist an Mitgliedern.
Die was jetzt bitte?
Die Demokristiani.
Ach so, weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Dass die sich aufgelöst hat, ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Vergleich mit der CDU ist mit 630.000 oder so.
Die waren auf jeden Fall auch eine lange Zeit da an der Macht.
Die waren ewig an der Regierung.
Also vergleichbar, denke ich, von der Größe.
Wenn ein Italiener hier in Westdeutschland groß geworden ist, brauchst du mir nicht zu sagen, wie lange die DG an der Regierung gewesen ist.
Nun ist die italienische Mentalität sicherlich im Laufe der letzten 1000 Jahre dauernd, ja, fremde Regierungen, sowieso ein bisschen anders, die Einstellung, glaube ich, gegenüber Autoritäten und Regierungen als in Deutschland.
Ja, das mag ja durchaus sein. Aber nehmen wir mal an... In den letzten Jungleworlds, das du bestimmt auch gelesen haben, nehme ich mal an, das Interview mit Giovanni Agnoli, dem Politikprof, der hier im OSI mal gewesen ist, noch emeritierte. Also ich meine, zu der Frage, weiß er das auch nicht, so beispielsweise, ich meine, er befürchtet auch Verhärtung des Systems.
Aber was wir doch wollen, ist, nehmen wir mal an, ich würde dir jetzt den Unwahrscheinlichkeitsdreif in die Hand geben. Du griffst jetzt den Schalter in die Hand und musst einfach nur deine Vision jetzt geben. Und die wird dann wahr. Also jetzt sag doch mal... Ja, deine Vision. Was wäre dann das Bestmöglichste, was aus dieser Geschichte jetzt werden könnte?
Die Aufhebung der Knechtschaft des Menschen durch den Menschen.
Okay, aber dann weiß ich nicht ganz, was du willst. Weil ich kenne das als Formulierung, dass im Sozialismus ja eben genau das Problem ist, ne im Kapitalismus, Entschuldigung, dass der Mensch den Mensch ausbeutet und im Sozialismus ist es eben genau umgekehrt. So, und was ist jetzt das System, das du dann wolltest oder die Art und Weise, wie es funktioniert?
Ich habe dich jetzt nicht so richtig verstanden, akustisch irgendwie.
Na, ich kenne da diesen Satz, im Kapitalismus beutet der Mensch den Menschen aus. Im Sozialismus ist es genau umgekehrt. Das kann ich dir nicht genau sagen, aber die Frage an dich war jetzt, wie stellst du dir das vor, dass der Mensch nicht mehr den Menschen ausbeutet?
So, mal, äh, die Leichtgefrage hast du nicht, ne? Ich meine, das ist wirklich ein bisschen zu abstrakt.
Ja, da kannst du heute noch ein bisschen drüber nachdenken.
Ja, genau, und dann rufst du vielleicht wieder an, Riccardo, weil bis jetzt war das so unergiebig, dass ich jetzt einfach mal Schluss mache und lieber jemand anderes dran nehme. Vielleicht hat der was der schon mal nicht.
Ja, hi, hier ist der Martin. Ich hätte auch etwas zu den Verwirrungstheorien beizutragen. Und zwar finde ich es immer ganz interessant, die Verschwörungstheorien der Vergangenheit zu betrachten, wenn man eben schon ein bisschen mehr weiß. Und darauf vielleicht auch was, was heute mitnimmt. Also ich kann nur zum Hans irgendwie sagen, der ist ja immer noch verboten. Und das war ja damals auch eine Verschwörungstheorie. Das wisst ihr vielleicht, ich würde es nur noch mal ganz kurz umreißen wollen. Das waren drei Leute, die sich da zusammengetan haben. Einer aus der Industrie, das war der DuPont. Der hatte gerade mit der Chemiefaser einen Patent gehabt und wollte halt den billigen, robusten Naturhand verdrängen. Dann gab es den Hearst. Das war der Chef von der Drogenverfolgungsbehörde, die die Prohibition so an die Wand gefahren hat. Das hat ja nicht geklappt, das wissen wir alle. Da hat es sich nicht durchgesetzt, irgendwie Drogen zu verbieten. Insofern brauchte er für seinen Apparat, den er ja aufgebaut hatte, eine kompensative Droge. Und das war in dem Falle der Hans. Und letztendlich vielleicht sogar der Wichtigste, der Harry Enzlinger. Das war der, ach Scheiße, jetzt habe ich es verwechselt. Ich bin halt auch schon ein bisschen bekifft, das ist halt der Nachteil der Droge. Harry Enzlinger war das mit den...
Hey, willst du uns jetzt was hier über den Hans erzählen?
Ja, aber er hat in jeden Fall Verwirrung gestiftet, was?
Ja, klasse.
Ja, jetzt aber mal ganz kurz, was war daran die Verschwörungstheorie?
Das war halt schon eine Praxis in der Verschwörung, weil der Enzlinger, von dem ich gerade erzählt habe, das war ja der, der diesen Verfolgungsapparat übernommen hatte und weiterführte. Und Herr Öst, das hatte ich jetzt verwechselt, weil ich hatte die Notizen gemacht und bin jetzt hier verrutscht, Herr Zeillist. Das war der, der diese ganzen Schmierblätter hatte, also ein riesen Medienmogul, der einfach da permanent Storys, so bildmäßig, diese Storys brachte. Der Hanf, die Todes, Droge und Mörder unserer Jugend. Und da gab es auch ganz komische Filme, die sie damals gemacht haben, die gibt es jetzt im Hanfmuseum auch noch zum Angucken. Nette satirische Zeitdokumente. Und haben letztendlich bewirkt, dass es bis heute der Hanf verboten ist.
Aber was ist daran eine Verschwörungstheorie?
Ich meine, das ist nicht die Frage. Die Frage war irgendwie, was passiert jetzt mit Deutschland? Also ich meine, wahrscheinlich...
Warte mal, wir können das aber mal zum Anlass nehmen, wenn wir schon über Verschwörungen reden. Also Verschwörungstheorien lassen sich ganz leicht basteln. Man braucht bloß ein paar Komponenten, also das ist halt modulmäßig aufgebaut. Du brauchst eine Organisation, die muss was zu verheimlichen haben, sonst wäre es halt keine Verschwörung dann irgendwie. Und dann kommt ein Ereignis, möglichst mysteriös, vielleicht auch möglichst gewaltsam. Und es ist eine sofortige Aufklärung gar nicht möglich. Und vor diesem Hintergrund können dann die Spekulationen, die Theorien irgendwie wachsen. Das heißt, wenn morgen rauskäme, dass Helmut Kohl den Finanzverwalter selber aufgehängt hat und das Geld kam aus dem Vatikan, ist es langweilig. Dann ist die Verschwörungstheorie dahin, dann weiß man es einfach. Aber das wird so schnell natürlich nicht passieren. Also so, man kann mit diesen Komponenten zig Verschwörungstheorien irgendwie aufbauen.
Ingredenzien sind da für viele neue Verschwörungstheorien.
Ja, also eben. Und wenn man sich zum Beispiel... Also es gibt eine Institution, die sich hervorragend, wenn wir den Strang spinnen wollen, eignet. Das ist die Atlantikbrücke e.V. Der Vorsitzende ist niemand anders als Dr. HC Walter Leisler-Kieb. Weitere Vorstandsmitglieder sind so Persönlichkeiten wie der Volker Rühe, der Peter Prinz Wittgenstein. Also lauter Leute, die übrigens auch im Zusammenhang mit dieser Spendenangelegenheit irgendwie auftauchen. Der Verein hat eine ganz interessante Satzung, die sehr schwammig formuliert ist. Deshalb geht es irgendwie um die Förderung der transatlantischen Beziehung und dies und das. Wenn man sich die Mitgliedsliste anguckt, der Vorsitzende ist irgendwie vom Kuratorium der Hilma Kopper von der Deutschen Bank usw. Das heißt, da ist so alles Mitglied, das Rang und Namen hat. Es liest sich ungefähr so, als sei es ein ziviler Teil der NATO. Die NATO hat ja so ihre militärischen Interessen.
Ja, ist es doch auch irgendwie. Die deutsch-amerikanische Freundschaft.
Genau, die deutsch-amerikanische Freundschaft, aber eben nicht auf militärische Aktionen bedrückt, sondern auf wirtschaftlich-politische Beziehung, die Förderung des gegenseitigen Verständnisses diesseits und jenseits des Atlantiks usf. Das ist jetzt erstmal nur die Organisation, die was zu verbergen hat. Jetzt nehmen wir das Ereignis. Das sind diese diversen Geldkoffer, die hier durch die Kante getragen werden, die wir in der Tat nicht aufgehen können, weil da hängt einfach viel zu viel dran. Da geht es wahrscheinlich noch um weit größere Beträge. Es wird ja auch nur das zugegeben, was ein Stück weit drin ist. Aber ich sag mal, ich finde eigentlich mit den Verschwörungstheorien sind wir dieses Jahrtausend irgendwie am Ende. Das hat sich einfach alles bewahrheitet. Und wir brauchen jetzt das auch nicht mehr Verschwörungstheorien zu benennen, sondern wir stellen fest, es gibt Leute, die scheren sich ein Scheißdreck um das offizielle Drehbuch, die drehen einfach gerne ein.
Du kannst nicht sagen, dass es mit Verschwörungstheorien zu Ende ist. Also es ist einfach eine Tatsache. So funktioniert das menschliche Denken. Bevor etwas Wahrheit ist irgendwie, ist es wie ein Mordfall. Du hast einfach Indizien und du versuchst dir zusammenzureimen, was passiert ist. Und wenn du zu wenig Indizien hast, dann kannst du daraus Verschwörungstheorien machen. Und zwar beliebig viele. Der Herr von Brauchitsch hat in seinem Buch zu Verschwörungstheorien gesagt, die gibt es. Aber das ist genau das Problem der Verschwörungstheorien, dass die Leute halt einfach, wenn ihnen die Informationen fehlen, nachdenken und umspielen.
Ja, aber ganz genau das ist das Problem dieses Punktes. Haben wir noch Hörer? Ja, haben wir noch. Ganz kurz, aber das ist ja exakt.
Ja hallo, hier ist Frank.
Hallo Frank.
Ich bin 36, ruf aus Berlin an. Und ich habe eine Weltverschwörungstheorie. Und auch, also die hat jetzt nichts mit den konkreten Sachen zu tun.
Wollen wir die hören? Oder wollen wir die lieber nicht hören?
Naja, aber ich hab noch einen Vorschlag. Und zwar, ich bin der Meinung, wir haben einen Hardwarefehler. Wir müssten mehr direkte Demokratie machen, also unsere Verfassung ändern. Der Bürger müsste praktisch in ein politisches Verfahren mit direkt einbezogen werden. Und Mandate müssten begrenzt werden. Also sprich, Bundeskanzler darf halt nur maximal als B-Pajon Bundeskanzler sein und nicht 16 Jahre lang.
Guter, vernünftiger Beitrag.
Ja, aber kann ich noch kurz was zu meiner Verschwörung...
Wen hast du denn zu bieten? Die Illuminaten, die Freire Maurer, die Wissenschaften? Bitte?
Ach nee, den wollen wir nicht.
Robert Anton Wilson.
Den kennen wir schon.
Den kennen wir schon, den lieben wir alle.
Dein Beitrag war wirklich vernünftig.
Ja, aber ich frage ganz kurz, dann könnte man ja aus Martins Beitrag aber Schlussfolger an, das Regierungsauftrag müsste es doch eigentlich sein, den Zusammenhängen mehr Informationen zuzuführen, damit es weniger Verschwörungstheorien gibt, weil wir wollen ja keine Verschwörungstheorien, sondern wir wollen wissen, was hier läuft. Und insofern wäre so ein Akteneinsichtsrecht oder doch zumindest ein Staatswesen, also gut, die maschinenlesbare Regierung.
Nein, und einfach eine transparent funktionierende Regierung und so die Netze.
Du meinst in dem Moment, wo der Koffer irgendwie nicht aus schwarzem Leder, sondern aus irgendwie Acrylglas wäre, den Herr Schäuble entgegen nimmt und wenn er damit 100.000 Mark Geld koffern durch den Bundestag läuft, dann wäre uns das allen klar, wenn wir verabschieden würden.
Das Problem ist, das ist eine Utopie. Dieses System würde nicht funktionieren. Wenn wir wissen würden, was passiert, würden wir so ein System nicht mehr haben wollen.
Ja, das ist ja was darum gelaufen. Und was wollen wir dann?
Ich meine, das ist ja jetzt gerade so.
Wir wollen jetzt eigentlich das, was da läuft, so richtig wollen, tun wir das, glaube ich.
Der Hörer hat gesagt, es müsste mehr Mitspracherecht geben, mehr Transparenz geben. Ich habe gesagt, dann würden wir das System nicht mehr wollen. Weil wir würden sehen, dass ziemlich viel nicht nach unseren moralischen Grundsätzen läuft.
Aber das sehen wir so doch auch.
Die ganze Affäre kommt bedauerlicherweise fünf Jahre zu früh ungefähr. Weil wir in ungefähr fünf Jahren so das Netz sich einfach so viel weiterentwickelt haben wird, dass erstmal der Großteil der Wirtschaft im Netz, im Internet stattfinden wird. Jedenfalls wahrscheinlich ein Drittel bis die Hälfte ungefähr im Internet bereits erwirtschaftet werden wird. Dessen, was im Moment an Wertschöpfung da ist.
Und du meinst dann keiner CCC für Transparenz?
Und ja, naja, dann ist auch der Umgang mit dem Medium, dann ist es so allgegenwärtig, dass es sich auch dafür eignet, um damit dann Politik zu betreiben, um damit zu wählen, beispielsweise, um damit einfach viele gemeinsam über viele kleine Dinge abzustimmen, über die man heute so aus praktischen Gründen einfach gar nicht abstimmen kann, weil es zu viel Zeit kostet, sich zu informieren und weil es zu viel Zeit braucht, dauernd wählen zu gehen und das alles sicherzustellen, wenn ich irgendwie einfach abends mich da kurz durch die Dinge durchklicken kann, die gerade anstehen und was weiß ich.
Die Frage ist, Pavel, willst du da irgendwie eine Form von elektronischer Demokratie oder elektronischer Bürokratie haben? Also Wilson hat ja mal gesagt, im Zeitalter der Bürokratie kann die Rede schon lange andauern, bis sich eine Papierknappheit einstellt.
Beides, du kennst, ja, also eines der schönen, der besten Sprüche des vergangenen Jahres war ja, wie ohne Chaos kann nichts entstehen und ohne Ordnung nichts existieren. Insofern, ich sag mal, beides ist sicherlich nötig. Und es ist sicher auch erforderlich, dass Entscheidungen, die getroffen sind, irgendwo festgehalten archiviert werden und dass es halt schon Strukturen gibt, wie das Ganze funktioniert und abläuft.
Also ich finde, wir können jetzt immer wieder in die Abteilung Menschenversuch gehen. Ich hab mir eine neue Frage mir an die Hörer überlegt. Ich meine, wir können es ja mal andersrum versuchen. Was wären, nehmen wir mal an, wir würden jetzt das bestehende Regierungssystem, was wir auf Grundgesetz und dem ganzen Kram nicht haben. Wir würden jetzt ein völlig neues System schaffen. Wir würden jetzt einen Open Source, Linux-basierten Grundgesetz anders schaffen. Welche Anforderungen hätten wir dann?
Darf ich eine These ausstellen? Wenn wir das machen würden, würden sich Communities bilden.
Kritiker behaupten, das sei schon geschehen.
Die Staaten würden so einfach nicht mehr benötigt werden, weil die Communities hätten ihre eigenen Gesetze. Die Communities wären über die Welt verteilt.
Moment, kommst gleich dran, ja?
Werden verbunden irgendwie durch dicke Glasfasern und würden einfach so leben, wie sie wollen.
Aber meinst du nicht, dass die Communities, der Waffenhändler, doch eventuell etwaige Regulaturien, irgendwie Bedürfte so?
Die Community der Waffenhändler.
Na ja, das sind ja auch, das ist ja auch eine Community. Wir haben halt ein bisschen mehr Geld und ein bisschen andere Spielzeuge. Und mit der Spiel, mit den Spielzeugen können sie halt mal kurz irgendwie 80 Prozent der anderen Communities platt machen, oder?
Na gut, man braucht natürlich einen Hammer, damit das Ganze funktioniert, aber... Und wo hält der? Kennst du dieses schöne Punk-Stück so, irgendwie I've fought the law and the law won? Und das funktioniert einfach so, wenn, wie gesagt, wenn nicht gerade ausgerechnet die, die damit betraut sind, den Hammer zu schwingen, irgendwie damit auch das Gesetz einschlagen.
So, Moment, ich muss jetzt mal ans Telefon gehen, der war da schon.
Ja, danke, dass ich auch dran bin. Ich hab leider ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass ihr euch unheimlich gerne selber reden hört, aber ein Hörer ist noch dran. Okay, also mit dieser Community und so, wahrscheinlich wird sich der gleiche Trend durchsetzen wie in der gesamten Gesellschaft. Und es ist ja zu befürchten, dass dann die Todesstrafe irgendwie durchgesetzt wird oder irgend so ein Scheiß passiert. Das ist nicht so einfach. Man muss ja auch mal dran denken, dass also, ich weiß nicht, 30-40% der Weltbevölkerung noch nicht einmal in ihrem Leben telefoniert haben. Und die elektronische Vernetzung bringt für die Demokratie erst mal nichts, sage ich nur. Und dann ist die Frage, ob man nach Regeln abläuft und wie weit Verschwörungstheorien interessant sind und ob nicht die Verschwörungspraxis, die festgestellt ist, viel interessanter ist. Und da möchte ich nur so einen kleinen Einwurf machen, dass Sabine ja doch wohl recht hatte, dass die Qualität, was jetzt durchgezogen ist oder was so erscheint für uns als Medieninteressierte, ja doch was ganz anderes ist, als wenn einer mal auf einen Jagdausflug geht mit seiner Freundin. Da sind irgendwie auf der einen Seite so menschliche Schwächen und auf der anderen Seite Systemverstöße. Und die Frage für ein demokratisches Publikum ist immer, wie weit sie toleriert sind.
Die Systemverstöße? Aber was wäre dein Ansatz jetzt?
Die Dürmsten Kälber wählen heute noch immer ihre Schlechter selber.
Na ja, ok, aber hast du denn nicht den Eindruck, dass ein Großteil der Bevölkerung mittlerweile von den Schlechtern so dermaßen abgenervt ist, dass sie im Zweifelsfall einfach nicht mehr wählen gehen, weil sie einfach nicht mehr wissen, welches Übel sie unter den Angebotenden da sich wählen sollen?
Das weiß keiner mehr. Und APPD wählen ist auch noch eine Alternative oder sonst was. Also vielleicht macht jeder seinen Quatsch, aber wenn es darauf hinausläuft, dann Halleluja, dann sind die Waffenschieber doch am stärkeren Ende.
Das würde ich nicht sagen.
Also ich meine, meinst du nicht, dass man mit elektronischen Medien und mit dem, was wir jetzt an Internetinfrastruktur, beispielsweise in diesem, unserem Land, mal so ein geflügeltes Wort zu nehmen, haben, schon wesentlich bessere Möglichkeiten bieten würde, wenn wir gesetzliche Grundlage entsprechender Natur hätten, um uns zu informieren, was uns eigentlich betrifft. Also um tatsächlich die Vorgänge transparent zu machen. Oder findest du das total naiv?
Nein, ist richtig. Für die, die den Zugang zu dem System, über das die Information verteilt wird, müssen wir auf den richtigen Zugang finden und sich die Informationen aussuchen.
Das könnten wir doch in den Grundschulen bereits anfangen, den Kids zu vermitteln. Das könnten wir öffentlich zur Verfügung stellen, genauso wie wir öffentliche Wege haben, Bürgersteige genannt, auf die wir alle gehen können. Oder Briefkästen. Ich meine so, diese Datenbürgersteige Idee. Okay, altes Konzept. Aber dass man sagt, jeder Bürger hat das Recht auf ein Zugang zu diesem Medium. Und das halt entsprechend durch politische Maßnahmen zu fördern.
Ist wünschbar, ist wünschbar und wär wunderbar.
Herr Clinton macht das.
Nur das hat mit den alten Medien ja theoretisch immer funktioniert. Und sich so durchgesetzt, dass Bild immer noch die auf langen stärkste Zeitung ist in Deutschland. Und das ist das Problem. So seh ich das.
Ja gut, aber das ist eine generationsbedingte Sache, wäre meine Theorie, dem entgegenzuhalten. Weil es gibt natürlich eine Menge Leute, die brauchen das immer noch von irgendwelchen Fernsehmoderatoren abgesabelt und die müssen sich auch noch von Gottschalk oder Hans Meiser oder wie man auch immer verarschen lassen. Aber es gibt auch schon eine Generation, die tatsächlich ihre Informationsrealitäten über das Netz bezieht.
Du warst doch bei Hans Meiser, was sagst du gegen den Typen?
Der ist einfach ein Vollidiot.
Was?
Ich will ja nur sagen, die neue Generation ist auch nicht besser als die alte, insofern ist sie sich gerne genauso verarschen lässt.
Besser nicht, aber anders sicher. Und klar wird das nicht von oben funktionieren, aber einfach die ökonomischen Realitäten werden einfach ein anderes Bewusstsein schaffen. Und da wird auch über kurz oder lang die Politik oder unser politisches System nicht immun gegen sein, gegen das, was einfach in den nächsten 10 Jahren an Veränderungen weiter passieren wird auf allen Ebenen.
Ja, nun gut, ich denke immer auch, die Medien sind wie auch immer geartet, abhängig von dem, der die Informationen liefert. Und an sich so Time Warner, EMI oder Bertelsmann, oder was weiß auch ich immer, und AOL und riesige Zusammenschlüsse. Und die Informationen werden also durchgedrückt, egal über welches Medium, immer von denen, die leider auf dem größten Geldsack sitzen.
Na gut, aber da scheinst du mir noch etwas fern ab, von der technischen Praxis des Internets zu sein. Du kannst natürlich im Internet dir auch die Bildzeitung reinladen und kannst irgendwie bei denselben Stulle Geschichten bleiben. Aber du hast eben auch die Möglichkeit, in Diskussionsforen, im Service Fall selbst der Sender zu sein oder selbst eine Site aufzusetzen und Nachrichtenagentur zu werden oder was auch immer. Und die Hemmschwelle dazu, auch die ökonomische Hemmschwelle, ist schon mal deutlich geringer als wenn du einen Fernsehsender, einen Radiosender oder sowas aufmachen willst, wo du einfach mal erstmal ein paar hunderttausend abend dastehen musst.
Gut, alles zugestanden, dagegen ist mir nichts zu sagen. Man konnte auch vor hundert Jahren schon mit Kreide was an die Wand malen. Wie ich meine Informationen verbreite, das ist nicht der Punkt. Für mich ist der Punkt, dass immer irgendwo die Ideologie oder das gesellschaftlich notwendige falsche Bewusstsein mit stärkster Macht durchgesetzt wird.
Na so einfach ist das glaube ich nicht.
Na gut, dann mach ich es mir zu einfach. Vielleicht habe ich auch schon zu viel gesprochen, andere wollen vielleicht auch was sagen.
Ja, genau so sieht es aus. Wir machen nur kurz ein bisschen Musik und ich sage Dank für deinen Anruf. Ich sage noch mal die Nummer durch. Das ist 0331 70 97 110 Chaosradio bei Fritz.
Ja Kann denn Liebe Sünde sein?
Darf es niemand wissen, wenn man sich küsst?
Vor Glück kann das wirklich Sünde sein?
Konsequenz. Nordrhein-Westfalens Finanzminister Schleuser ist zurückgetreten. Er zog damit die Konsequenz aus der sogenannten Flugaffäre. Schleuser musste einräumen, dass er auf zwei von der Westdeutschen Landesbank bezahlten Dienstflügen seine Freundin mitgenommen hatte. Ministerpräsident Clement, der sich noch gestern vor seinen Parteifreund gestellt hatte, äußerte Verständnis für den Schritt. Rotstift. Rund 20.000 Menschen haben heute vor dem Landtag in Potsdam gegen die geplanten Streichungen im Kita-Bereich protestiert. Die Brandenburger Koalition will die Zuschüsse für Kindertagesstätten in diesem und im nächsten Jahr um 93 Millionen Mark kürzen. Appell. Bundeskanzler Schröder hat auf der Internationalen Holocaust-Konferenz in Stockholm zu einer stärkeren Zusammenarbeit gegen Neonazis aufgerufen. Dazu gehöre die geistige Auseinandersetzung mit dem Rassismus, sagte er. Schröder äußerte sich auch besorgt über eine mögliche Regierungsbeteiligung der rechtsgerichteten FPÖ in Österreich. Vorwurf. Die Hilfsorganisation für politische Opfer, HELP, hat gegen den Regisseur des Films Sonnenallee, Leander Hausmann, Strafanzeige gestellt. Sie wirft ihm Beleidigung der Maueropfer vor. Sonnenallee war mit über zwei Millionen Kinobesuchern der erfolgreichste deutsche Spielfilm im vergangenen Jahr. Basketball in der Bundesliga hat Alba Berlin gegen Braunschweig mit 85 zu 61 gewonnen. Alba bleibt damit an der Tabellenspitze.
Wetter.
Nachts zeitweise Regen ein bis drei Grad, am Tag ebenfalls leichter Regen zwei bis fünf Grad.
Das war das Fritz Info mit Falk Zilke und die Zeit 23 Uhr 33.
Kann es, kann denn Liebe Sünde sein? Nein, eigentlich nicht. Die Politiker lieben ihre Parteien, denn ihre Parteien geben ihnen Macht und wer Macht hat, kann die Welt regieren, kann Gesetze schützen und schaffen und so regiert man halt eben einfach, weil man seinen Staat liebt. Und deswegen ist das eigentlich alles so, wie es ist, in Ordnung.
Es gibt zwei griechische Götter für.
Krieg, Ares und Athene. Der Ares kämpft mit Waffen, die Athene kämpft mit Information. Und um Kriege zu gewinnen, braucht man Macht und Ares und Athene sind einfach die Werkzeuge, um die Macht zu sichern. Das bedeutet, eine Community braucht Zugang zu den Netzen, braucht Information, muss am besten alles wissen über die anderen und gleichzeitig braucht sie natürlich eine Exekutive, das heißt, sie braucht ein paar Bomben, die sie nicht benutzen muss oder vielleicht ab und zu mal gezielt von oben.
Wie gezielst du da jetzt gerade das Konzept für den bewaffneten Widerstand, die Weltrevolution oder für ein neues Gesellschaftssystem?
Nein, ich sag nur irgendwie, dass schon die alten Griechen wussten, wie man Macht erhält.
Ja nun, das erleben wir ja, aber im Moment ist ja nicht die Frage, wie wir Macht erhalten, sondern wie wir Macht loswerden.
Wieso, als CCC haben wir doch ganz schön Macht. Also wir wissen zumindest, was in Netzen los ist. Wir haben verdammt viel Macht. Und vielleicht haben wir mehr Macht als manche kleinen Guerilla-Armeen.
Weil wir mit Informationsbomben um uns werfen können.
Was hast du gesagt?
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was ihr da immer beim Vorstand besprecht, aber sowas krieg ich nicht mit.
Also ich meine, was wir zumindest irgendwie feststellen können, wenn es um Information geht, ist, dass es einige Facetten dieses Spiels gibt, wo sehr wenig bekannt ist und wo man auch nicht den Eindruck hat, dass irgendjemand Interesse daran hat, da Informationen zutage zu fördern. Ich gehe zum Beispiel hier mal die kleine Anfrage des FDP-Abgeordneten Coppelien an die Bundesregierung mit diesen Leunakten aus dem Kanzleramt. Da fragt er dann mal, geht die Bundesregierung bei dem Verschwinnen der Unterlagen von einer vorsässlichen Handlung aus und wie bewertet sie diese? Und da steht einfach nur beim gegenwärtigen Stand der Verwaltungsermittlung, lässt sich die Frage nicht beantworten und andere Fragen, wie gibt es Hinweise, wer einem Bundeskanzleramt Anweisungen zur Aktenvernichtung gegeben hat, die bisherigen Verwaltungsermittlungen gegenüber kein Aufschluss. Also es ist alles so, die Antworten sind alle so, ja eigentlich interessiert uns das auch nicht so. Und insofern, gut, okay, jetzt können wir sagen, was interessiert uns überhaupt diese Leunangeschichte? Das Kind ist eh in den Brunnen gefallen und der Kanzler war halt degadent und die Machtmöder halt erhalten.
700 Millionen von unserer Kohle sind in irgendwelche Kanäle geflossen. Ich meine, das war ungefähr, die so groß war der Kuchen bei Leuna, den sie offenbar untereinander aufgeteilt haben. Bei den Panzern waren es ja die 220 Millionen, die an Schmiergeldern geflossen sind. Und bei Leuna gehen die Schätzungen ungefähr bei 700 Millionen, so als die Größe des Kuchens dessen, was da irgendwo an Schwergel ist, auf den Kopf gehauen.
Ja, aber du sagst jetzt, unsere Kohle. Ich meine, im Grunde genommen zahlen wir Steuern, und das ist doch genau dieselbe Schutzgelderpression. Steuern in diesem Land hast du deine Ruhe. Du tust es nicht, hast du Stress. So ungefähr kann man das doch durchaus sehen.
Steuern in vernünftiger Höhe sind schon durchaus sinnvoll.
Nein, so kann man das durchaus sehen. Das ist echt mein Eindruck, wenn ich sehe, was mir da jeden Monat abgebucht wird. Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, was damit passiert. Ich bezweifle, dass jeder Markt in gute Dinge umgesetzt wird.
Wir können ja mal über die historische Herleitung reden. Es gibt da dieses Grundgesetz und damals gab es auch noch ein Staatsverständnis. Und das lautet so grob, wir alle betreiben eine gemeinsame Infrastruktur, genannt Staat irgendwie. Da bestimmen wir gemeinsam, wer da unsere Repräsentanten sind, wer da irgendwie die Ampelfarben festlegt und diese Dinge. Und wir zahlen alle ein bisschen Geld dafür, damit hier die Dinge, die wir gemeinsam nutzen, die Schulen, die Bürgersteige, die Straßen und der ganze Mumpitz, finanziert werden können. So hat das alles mal vom Modell her ausgesehen.
Ja, aber versuch mal die Ampelfarbe zu ändern. Du hast keine Chance.
Du darfst doch an die Marken auswählen.
Na ja, ich meine, wenn sich jetzt die Politiker darüber einigen würden, dass irgendwie Grün einfach eine bessere Farbe ist, um irgendwie anzuhalten, dann würden sie das schon durchsetzen. Aber so sind unsere Repräsentanten immer gerade nicht gepolt, sondern die Ampelfarbe wird ja de facto festgelegt von der Firma Siemens, die in diesem Land nun mal die Ampels liefert, die entsprechende Kohle haben und die dann eben losgehen und den Politikern so Dinge wie Verkehrslenkung irgendwie aufschwatzen. Es gibt ja auf der Autobahn Hannover Berlin irgendwie so ein System, das dazu führt, dass da permanent Stau ist, weil da irgendwie immer unterschiedliche Geschwindigkeiten, je nach Laune der Siemenstechniker festgelegt werden. Das Ganze ergibt zwar keinen Sinn, aber führt eben dazu, dass eigentlich...
Sieht gut aus.
Sieht gut aus und ein nicht unerheblichen Teil des Geldes geht eben an diesen mehr oder weniger Staatsbetrieb. Sie werden von dem anderen ja sagen, es sei eine Bank.
Ich meine Verschwendung durch Unfähigkeit, das bin ich gewohnt, da habe ich mich mit umgefunden. Aber irgendwie so, dass irgendjemand wirklich vorsätzlich an die Kohle rangeht, so dass...
Ja, aber das ist doch, ich meine, wenn wir uns mit dieser Ampelsituation abfinden, dann ist es doch eigentlich genau dasselbe. Weil da wird doch auch nicht unerheblich ein Teil des Geldes geht ja nicht in irgendwas Sinnvolles, sondern in denjenigen, der bestochen wird, weil er die Entscheidung schreibt.
Ich meine, ein bisschen Schwund ist immer, da kommt man...
Das war doch genau deine These. Du hast gesagt, wir zahlen Schutzgelder und das stimmt. Es sind Schutzgelder, wir wissen ganz genau, wenn wir die nicht zahlen, geht es uns dreckig. So zahlt die Industrie Schutzgelder, weil sie wissen genau, wenn sie es nicht zahlen, dann geht es ihnen dreckig. Und letztendlich zahlt jeder Bürger, jede Stadt, jeder Betrieb, jeder zahlt Schutzgelder an die Regierung, weil sonst, wenn sie das nicht mehr zahlen, sagt die Regierung, okay, dann guckt, was mit euch passiert, und dann gibt es ein Problem, dann gibt es Chaos.
Ich gehe noch mal kurz ans Telefon, Hi, hier ist Sabine.
Ist noch die Frage nach dem neuen Systemmodell aktiv?
Klar.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Also ganz pragmatisch würde ich sagen, Volksentscheid ist doch immer eine feine Sache, weil da verkehrt sich das mit dem Wählen gehen.
Also da ist das doch immer für den gut, der gewinnt.
Du meinst jetzt Volksentscheid zu konkreten Fragen, oder?
Ja, genau. Wirklich nicht die Streiten, nicht die Politiker entscheiden lassen, sondern das Volk.
Das war jetzt ja in der Schweiz.
Ich hab mal von einem Schweizer ein kleines nettes Detail gehört, das würde da jetzt sehr gut reinpassen. Da ging es eben um die Frage, da war ein Grundstück, wo die Frösche immer hin und her wanderten und jetzt entbrannte eben eine große Kontroverse, weil da gebaut werden sollte und weil auf der anderen Seite halt aber die Frösche da eigentlich gerne lang wandern. Ja, dann wurde da halt ein Volksentscheid gemacht an der Stelle, der so aussah, okay, entweder es darf da gebaut werden, so konnten die Leute entscheiden oder so die Gemeinde kauft jetzt dieses Grundstück und dafür erhöhen sich im nächsten Jahr die Steuern um 0, 002 Prozent.
Das entscheidet bei uns auch das Voll.
Das heißt, die konnten ganz konkret sagen, ist es mir im nächsten Jahr irgendwie die 20 Mark wert, dass da die Frösche lang wandern können, oder sind mir die Frösche scheißegal und ich will die 20 Mark behalten? Und ausgegangen ist es so, dass die Frösche halt, dass das Grundstück für die Frösche gekauft wurde und jeder halt sein Zwang gegeben hat, fand ich schon irgendwie ein besseres System als alle fünf Jahre ein Kreuzchen machen.
Moment, aber das funktioniert sehr gut auf so einer regionalen Ebene. Wo du da super gut den Überblick hast, ja genau, ich will 20 Mark bezahlen für dieses Grundstück, da kannst du dich korrekt entscheiden. Aber sobald 80 Millionen Leute über irgendwelche Themen befragt werden, die auch demagogisch ausgeschlachtet werden können, kannst du unter Umständen ein Problem haben. Also Jörg Heider steht auch auf Volksentscheide.
Weil der peitscht die Leute derartig ein, dass sie dann in seinem Sinne abstimmen.
Eine Vorbedingung ist, dass man die Leute in ihrer Schulzeit auch versucht zu kritischen Staatsbürgern ranzubilden und nicht...
Ja, aber das kommen jetzt sehr abgehoben nachher. Weil die Leute, die hier im Moment heranwachsen, die sind alle geprägt von 15 Jahren Regierungspolitik im Bildungswesen von Kohle. Und der hat die Kohle für alles Mögliche ausgegeben, aber nicht dafür, dass wir hier sinnvoll ausgebildete Staatsbürger rumlaufen haben, sondern wir haben hier irgendwie ausgebildete Knechte, die genau für das geflüchtet sind, wofür sie gebraucht werden, um die Siemens-Ampeln heranzuschrauben und irgendwie die Bestechungsgelder weiterzuleiten.
Auch für Beamtenkarrieren eignet sich hier so eine Schulausbildung.
Aber freier Menschen haben wir nicht. Und insofern, also nehmen wir mal das mit dem Volksentscheid, nehme ich mal in die Liste auf, aber ich koppel es mit mit Dezentralisierung, wenn es recht ist.
Naja, ich meine, grundsätzlich geht es ja auch um Bestechungsgelder. Und ich meine, das ist doch das Übel der Gesellschaft, oder? Also das Geld an sich und so ist das natürlich mit dem Geld abschaffen so eine Sache, aber vielleicht so für ein zukünftiges System auch unbedingt notwendig, weil...
Wo brauchen wir denn das Geld?
Na, ich meine, letztendlich, früher sind die doch auch ohne ausgekommen. Ich meine, klar muss es irgendeine Art von Zahlungsmittel geben in dieser Übergangszeit, aber vielleicht wäre in der Übergangszeit das irgendwie gut, so das Erben abzuschaffen.
Also, Geld ist schon...
Wo soll das Geld hingehen?
Das Geld hinzunehmen, der schon Geld hat, und das ist ja das Problem, oder?
Unter anderem, eigentlich der.
Also Geld ist schon eine relativ vernünftige Erfindung. Das vergammelt nicht, das kann man transportieren, das ist schon in Ordnung mit dem...
Und unterm Gelde hängt zum Gelde, drängt auch alles, wusste ich, um der Herr Goethe zu berichten, aber das ist doch irgendwie eine komische Eigenart des Menschen, da so dem Materiellen behaftet zu sein, oder?
Nee, das finde ich ganz normal eigentlich, aber darüber können wir noch weiter diskutieren.
Darüber können wir gerne noch weiter diskutieren, aber was würdest du als alternatives Modell, was würde dir sozusagen vorschieben? Also jetzt auch mal auf das Erben gefragt, so wie würdest du das denn regeln wollen?
Ja, ganz klar, ich meine, erstmal müssten sich alle Menschen einig sein, dass wir vielleicht irgendwie Humanisten sind, und wenn dann irgendwie die Leute, die das viele Geld haben und das natürlich auch behalten wollen, irgendwie mal einsehen wurden, dass es ihnen selbst natürlich nutzt, aber andere verhungern und dass es irgendwie nicht humanistisch ist, dann könnte man das vielleicht ja so einrichten, dass irgendwie wir einfach mal feststellen, wie viele Menschen wir hier so auf dem Planeten sind, wie viel Kohle wir so haben, und dann wird einfach mal geteilt. Und ich meine, sicherlich kann es nicht von heute auf morgen erfolgen, aber wenn alles, was an Reichtum vererbt wird, wo Leute irgendwelche Scheiße plötzlich die super Karriere haben, bloß weil Daddy irgendwie mal ein Lotto gewonnen hat, das ist doch nicht gerecht. Ich meine, das Leben ist nicht fair, das wissen wir alle, aber... Ich meine, wenn um...
Ja, aber das scheint mir noch ein bisschen unausgereift zu sein, weil man dann einfach viel zu viel Zwang ausüben muss auf die Leute, die was haben. Das funktioniert nicht. Das ist ein etableristisches Argument.
Das ist wirklich nicht das Argument, aber die Sache ist, wie willst du den Zustand ändern? Und wenn wir jetzt tatsächlich drauf warten, bis alle sich darüber einig sind, dass sie Humanisten sind, dann befürchte ich, werden wir das einfach nicht mehr erleben.
Das wäre vielleicht schon irgendwie in eine politische Richtung. Ich meine, da gibt es ja auch so ein klassischer Zitat, nicht?
Die Idee wird zur materiellen Gewalt, wenn sie die Massen ergreift.
Also, wenn man teilen sollte, dann wäre das auch mal ein Problem.
Von wem ist das?
Irgendso Marx oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob unsere ostdeutschen Hörer damit nicht die eine oder andere Assoziation verbinden.
Also ich bin ein ostdeutscher Hörer. Und ich finde es ziemlich klasse, was ihr da heute vom Stapel lasst. Also das über den Staatsrundfunk gibt mir ja noch ein bisschen Hoffnung.
Ja, ist doch staatlich gefördert oder?
Wir sind nicht staatlich gefördert, wir kriegen die Koffer so hoch.
Aber ich meine, die Idee mit der Geldfrage und damit auch mit der Machtfrage, die ist sicherlich eine Zentrale, weil die Frage ist ja aber auch ein bisschen so, ab welchem Moment sind Leute überhaupt bereit, irgendwie Geld abzugeben oder so was?
Ja, das ist es ja, das Geld verdirbt ja den Charakter, oder?
Ja, das hat Pol Pot auch gedacht, also das ist jetzt zwar hässlicher Einwurf, aber das erinnert mich einfach daran. Von dem habe ich jetzt keinen Zitat, den würde ich auch nicht zitieren unbedingt. Aber das weißt du, was ich meine? Das ist die Idee vom Steinzeitkommunismus. Wir wollen kein Geld, wir sind alle Humanisten und die Lehrer werden entweder...
Jeder nimmt sich nur was er braucht und arbeitet so viel wie er Bock hat.
Ich meine, das ist eine schöne Vision.
Die Vision ist schön, aber sie ist nicht umsetzbar.
Ja, weil das Bewusstsein nicht da ist, weil das Bewusstsein immer noch dem Geld hinterher strebt.
Was ich denke, was ein Weg sein könnte, ist, es fehlt doch die Transparenz. Es fehlt der Kontakt von der Basis bis zur Spitze. Und jetzt durch die Netze haben wir die Chance, mehr Kontakt zur Spitze zu gewinnen, mehr Transparenz. Und dann löst sich das alles auf. Das heißt, die Kontrolle, die gefordert wird und die wir einfach benötigen, die kann sich bilden, wenn es eine Transparenz gibt. Das heißt, was wir eigentlich fordern müssen, ist doch irgendwie offener Zugang zu den Informationen, wie unser Staat funktioniert. Wir wollen Einblick in die Akten, wir wollen, dass das alles online ist und dann ist gut.
Nein, Moment, ich sehe noch eine andere historische Chance, auf die uns unser Hörer, das Name ich nicht mitgeschrieben habe, auf die du Aufmerksam gemacht hast. Nämlich die Sache, wo man seine Zeit auch einsetzt. Weil diese Computerisierung der Gesellschaft hat ja noch eine andere Folge, nämlich voll Arbeit, also voll Beschäftigung für die ganze Bevölkerung gibt es auch nicht mehr. Also es ist völliger Unsinn, wird zwar von den Politikern auch angestrebt, aber nicht mehr damit die Leute glücklich sind, sondern damit sie nicht auf die Straße gehen und die Regierung stürzen oder anderen Unsinn machen oder auf einmal Massenorganfeiern.
Dieses blöde Wahlplakat von der SPD, Arbeit, Arbeit, Arbeit.
Nein, noch viel schlimmer fand ich, der Arbeit muss der Chef sein. Der Chef da, also das finde ich das allerletzte, das aller allerletzte und insofern die historische Chance war, ich glaube es ist auch generationsbedingt so. Die Generation meiner Eltern, die ist noch auf dem Konzept irgendwie, ja, man lebt um zu arbeiten und man arbeitet um dann in Rente zu gehen, um dann zu sterben so und die Leute in unserer Generation, die wissen schon, irgendwie arbeiten kann ich, irgendwie kann ich aber auch sein lassen, ich kann noch ausschlafen und dann geht die Welt auch nicht unter, was irgendwie für andere Leute noch völlig unvollstellbar ist. Für die ist es so, wenn sie nicht morgens um sieben aufstehen, dann haben sie gleich ein Unrechtsbewusstsein, dass es irgendwie einen Erschau hat.
Ja, das ist richtig, aber unsere Generation, die hängt ja auch noch dem Geld nach und vielleicht ist ja die nächste Generation, gerade weil es sich ja auch mit den Computern so vernetzt, nicht? Gar nicht mehr auf dieses Geld im Sinne von Scheine und Münzen fixiert, da geht das dann wahrscheinlich wirklich alles über Laptop und Karten und so und dann verliert das Geld ja auch irgendwie dieses Scheinezählen und Münzenklimpern.
Diese schwarze Magie, die das Geld mit sich bringt.
Und insofern könnte das ja vielleicht irgendwie doch auch zu diesem durchaus ernst gemeinten Vorschlag, dass doch alle bei demselben Stand irgendwie geboren werden sollten, dann mal enden, dass da einfach natürlich alles Computer erfasst wird, Mensch, Maschine, Symbiose, Schreite, in Japan gibt es eine ziemlich hohe Erbschaftssteuer, die liegt teilweise, glaube ich, bei bis zu 90 Prozent, je nachdem für was und das ändert vielleicht ein bisschen, aber auch nicht viel.
Ich meine, ein anderer Vorschlag war natürlich noch, wenn man so bei den Politikern und Geld redet, dass man vielleicht wie in Singapur den Politikern vernünftige Gehälter zahlen könnte.
Das sehen wir ja, wie das funktioniert.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass irgendwie ein Schäuble da irgendwie schlecht verdient hat oder irgendwelche Leute, die sich da in die Tasche gesteckt haben.
Ja, ja, eben, eben.
Also das glaube ich ist ein bisschen zu einfach, weil wie gut willst du sie denn bezahlen? Wieviel willst du ihnen geben?
So, dass sie nicht für Städte sind und so, dass sie die Wahlkampagnen finanzieren können.
Ja, aber mehr geht immer.
Manche Parteien kriegen doch Geld vom Staat für ihre vielen Kampagnen.
Man hat ja nicht den Eindruck, dass Geld irgendwie eine Sache ist, die befriedigt. Dass es irgendjemand gibt, der sagt, er hat genug Geld. Ja, das ist es, genau.
Gewinnmaximierung, oberstes Prinzip der Marktwirtschaft. Ich meine, das kriegt man im Unterricht erzählt. Und ich meine, es ist kein Wunder, dass die Menschen so werden.
Okay, an dieser Stelle möchte ich noch mal was zu Geld sagen, Poki. Wenn du Rundfunkgebühren zahlen würdest. Gut, dann wirst du ja wissen, dass es kein Staatsrundfunk ist. Es ist ein System, das von den Gebührenzahlern finanziert wird und durch Werbeeinnahmen natürlich. Und das Ganze wird kontrolliert von Gremien, die Rundfunkraten nennen. Die bestehen aus einem Parteienproport. Also der Staat hat da kein, wenn dann nur über die Rundfunkkarte. Ich wollte es nur mal klarstellen.
Interessant wusste ich ja wirklich in der Form auch noch nicht.
Ja, alles klar, Pogi.
Tschüss, bye-bye.
Wer bist du?
Ja, ich hatte vorhin schon mal angerufen. Frank aus Berlin. Ich wollte noch mal was anmerken, und zwar weil die Leute da gesagt haben, in Amerika ist so Datenfreiheit, also dazu muss ich mal sagen, also ich vermisse heute noch die Freigabe der Kennedy-Daten, denn die Freigabe der Roswell-Daten, die Daten über Majestic 12, wenn euch das was sagt.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel. Ich will ja nicht sagen, dass in Amerika kein korruptes Dekadent ist, irgendwie das System einiger weniger mächtiger ist, die alles tun, damit sie an der Macht bleiben herrscht. Ich sage nur, dass die Ausgangsvoraussetzung, dass es überhaupt wenigstens ein Gesetz gibt.
Ja, bloß ich muss dazu sagen, also das müsste doch so sein, dass jeder Bürger das Recht auf alle Daten hat. Bloß nun ist nicht jeder. Also ich bin zwar Computerfreak, aber kein Hacker und habe dadurch nicht die Möglichkeit, in irgendwelche Systeme reinzukommen.
Du meinst wirklich auf alle Daten? Im Sinne von auf alle, auch auf deine Daten?
Ja, alle. Auch?
Und was ist mit deiner Privalsphäre? Gibt es nicht Daten, wo du sagen würdest, also hm?
Ja sagen wir gut, okay, also die Daten von meinem Nachbarn oder so, die gehen mich ja persönlich nicht an. Aber die Daten, die Regierung sammeln, jetzt über irgendwelche Schweinereien, über Geheimprojekte oder irgend sowas, die müssten veröffentlicht werden. Und da muss ich euch mal sagen, warum...
Du hast gerade die Hacker-Ethik vorgelesen, du musst uns nichts sagen, wir verstehen das.
Ja, nee, warum veröffentlicht ihr da nicht mehr? Habt ihr da Angst vor der Regierung oder...
Kannst du lesen, www.ccc.de, genau das steht da.
Naja, ich meine, wir machen ja schon solche Sachen, aber...
Ja, man hört immer nur so am Rande, so ein bisschen was, aber ihr macht da auch nicht mal so einen Schnall.
Nee, das ist auch klar, weil du kannst dir das mal vorstellen, wir haben damit vor 15 Jahren angefangen. Damals waren wir noch in den Datennetzen, wo die gar nicht davon ausgegangen sind, dass da überhaupt jemand reinguckt. Sprich, es war sehr viel einfacher, da weiterzukommen. Aber irgendwann haben die halt auch angefangen, uns die Männer mit den Maschinengewehren und den schwarzen Limousinen und sonst was zu schicken. Weil es ist ja nicht so, dass sie sich dieser Gefährdung, die sich durch ihre Computer und so, da ergeblich bewusst sind und dass sie darauf nicht reagieren würden.
Ja, bloß ich bin aber der Meinung, ihr habt ja nun wirklich richtig jetzt Fachwissen. Warum schützt ihr euch nicht anders? Ihr könnt da so einen Gegenpart.
Es könnte ja sein, dass wir das längst tun, aber es ist ja glaube ich keine kluge Idee, sich Institutionen öffentlich entgegenzustellen, die irgendwie einen 2- bis 3-stelligen Millionenetat zur Verfügung haben und unter anderem bewaffnetes Personal.
Naja, wenn man ein richtiger Hacker ist, dann kann man auf andere Art und Weise zu Geld kommen und damit Geld wieder vernünftig einsetzen.
Ja, aber über Geld reden wir hier eigentlich auch gar nicht. Wir reden eher über gesellschaftliche Probleme, weil nehmen wir mal an, wir hätten alle diese Fähigkeiten, die du da gerade aufzählst.
Ja, jeg von aus.
Ja, okay, dann brauchen wir aber trotzdem noch irgendwie eine Vision, wohin soll es dann gehen.
Und wir maßen uns auch nicht an, auch wenn wir hier heute Abend vielleicht über alle möglichen Dinge reden, nun wirklich jetzt anderen vorzuschreiben, so was sie zu tun oder zu lassen.
Ich meine, die Frage ist doch, welche Gesellschaft wollen wir? Nehmen wir mal an, wir können jetzt bestimmte Informationen öffnen.
Für mich sind das alle Lemminge.
Aber mein Eindruck ist, die sind schon teilweise aufgerüttelt. Bloß das Problem, was sie haben, ist, dass sie bei dieser Aufrüttelung mittlerweile bei der Frage gelandet ist, okay, wenn das tatsächlich so beschissen ist und wenn die Welt tatsächlich nicht aus ein paar Leuten, die Spinnen bestehen, sondern aus ein paar Leuten, die hier irgendwie eiskalte Diele zählen, was ist die Alternative? Und ich finde, du gehst ein bisschen an der Frage vorbei.
Die Masse ist doch zufrieden. Die Masse hat schon längst ihren Volksentscheid.
Die Masse wird doch auch nur programmiert von unfälschten Mächtigen.
Hör mal zu, es gab einen Volksentscheid über einen Maschendrahtzaun, ja? Dieser Volksentscheid wurde im Fernsehen ausgeführt, über Wochen. Und das ist das, was die Masse irgendwie hat. Die hat das Fernsehen und die ist glücklich.
Das ist die Manipulation im Unterbewusstsein.
Aber meinst du nicht, dass generationsbedingt, wie gesagt, ich hab da so komische Hoffnung, weil ich irgendwie kenne eine Menge Leute, die haben schon echt Internet jeden Tag, aber Fernsehen kennen die kaum. Haben sie auch nicht die Zeit zu, weil Fernsehen kostet irgendwie viel Zeit und kommt wenig bei rum, im Gegensatz zu Internet. Also insofern, okay. Ich stimme dir zu, aber ich finde, du musst auch uns das Recht einräumen, dass wir mal nach den Konzepten fragen. Weil bloß weil wir die technischen Möglichkeiten vielleicht haben, hat es das ja noch lange nicht, dass wir euch auch gleich sagen können, wie die Gesellschaft aussehen soll.
Das nicht, aber ich denke mal so eine Gruppe wie euch, die gibt es doch, die wird doch weltweit so eine Gruppe geben. Und irgendwo, das weiß ich nicht, müsstet ihr doch so ein Potenzial irgendwann mal erreichen, dass ihr irgendwo so etwas wie eine Erweckung von allen.
Aber alleine die Welt zu retten, ich meine, da arbeiten wir zwar dran.
Ja, vor allem brauchst du dich auch nicht, also nichts gegen den CCC, aber du musst dich ja nicht auf eine andere Organisation verlassen. Mach es doch selber, du kannst Sender sein.
Naja, ich informiere mich ja schon.
Ja, aber du kannst auch was rausgeben. Du hast ja auch was zu sagen und du weißt auch Sachen. Und du kannst genauso gut was rausgeben. Du musst nicht nur der CCC machen.
Das ist richtig, aber das heißt ja nur nicht, dass ich was ich hier zu sagen habe, immer so der richtige Weg ist, oder?
Nee, aber du kannst in die Newscopes gehen und du kannst irgendwie da mit den Leuten diskutieren. Und da, wo du was zu sagen hast, gibst du deinen selbst dazu. Das ist richtig interessant zu lesen.
Nee, aber ich denke, das Kernproblem hat er angerissen. Das Kernproblem lautet repräsentative Instanzen. Weil in dem Moment, wo du sagst, ey, könnt ihr nicht mal die Welt retten? Oder ey, du Grüne könnt ihr nicht mal machen? Otto Schillig kannst du es nicht machen? Oder Gerhard Schröder oder wer auch immer. Oder CCC kannst du es nicht machen? Dass diese repräsentative Instanzen, die geraten dann in so eine komische Rolle, wo sie auf einmal wesentlich mehr Dinge entscheiden müssen, als sie eigentlich können. Und die sind, also wenn du dir Bonn oder jetzt Berlin halt, wenn du dir diese politischen Institutionen oder Anhörungen auch nur eine einzige Mal im Detail anguckst, dann stellst du fest, die Leute sind da nicht in erster Linie dekadent, doof, ignorant oder irgendwas, sondern in erster Linie sind die überfordert. Die sind überfordert damit, weil sie so viele Interessen repräsentieren sollen und so viele Themen mit sich beschäftigen müssen, die sie überhaupt nicht begreifen, dass sie Kacke machen. Die machen einfach Kacke und wenn dann einer kommt und bietet ihnen Koffergeld für irgendeine Entscheidung, dann verstehen sie zwar auch nicht unbedingt, was die Entscheidung für Konsequenzen hat, ist aber im Zweifelsfall die angenehmere Entscheidung, weil man hat ja den Koffergeld und falsch machen tut man sowieso egal, was man macht.
Das wäre ja Bestechung.
Ja gut, aber alles andere stimmt eben auch nicht.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass es Bestechung ist. Ich glaube, es ist Schutzgeld. Das ist echt eine Unterschiede.
Jetzt hören wir mal Musik und dann nehmen wir den Nüstenhörer. Aber danke für die Anregung.
Im Studio sind Martin, Pavel, Andi und ich bin Sabine. Geht gleich weiter 0331 70 97 110.
Ja.
Chaosradio bei Fritz. Am Telefon ist Sascha und er ruft aus Wien an. Hört uns über Real Audio.
Ich höre die Sendung jetzt schon seit eineinhalb Stunden. Und was mir dazu eingefallen ist, es hat einmal Robert Heinlein seinen Watzrost long sagen lassen. Autokratie oder jedes autoritäre System geht davon aus, dass einer gescheiter ist als alle anderen. Und die demokratischen Systeme gehen davon aus, dass alle miteinander gescheiter sind als einer. Und wie war das dann mit Galileo Galilei?
Ja, und sie dreht sich doch.
Sie bewegt sich doch.
Ja gut, aber damit hast du jetzt noch keinen, was wäre denn für dich der Lösungsansatz?
Na ja, es kommen sehr viele Anrufer, die sich irgendwo ein sehr basisdemokratisches System wünschen. Die Frage ist nur, bei diffizileren Fragen, wie weit es Sinn macht, wenn es darum geht, irgendwelche Entscheidungen zu treffen, die in sehr spezielle Gebiete gehen, fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht berufen, da jetzt irgendwie eine Stimme abzugeben, das könnte auch daran liegen, dass du ein gesundes Verhältnis dazu hast und sagst, wenn ich da nicht kompetent bin, dann tue ich das nicht.
Es gibt offenbar eine Krankheit, und von der sind Politiker standardmäßig befallen, dass wenn sie erstmal in der Position sind, entscheiden zu können, dann sind Sachfragen auf einmal egal und Kompetenz ist auch egal. Im Teil für Teil gibt man einen Gutachten, irgendwo ein Auftrag, das man bezahlt, das einem bestätigt, dass das, was man machen will, das Richtige ist. Wie willst du den wissenschaftlichen Anspruch, den ich da so ein bisschen bei dir raushöre, wie willst du den realisieren?
Na, es ist schon in der Praxis so eine Sache, eine Frage, wenn man an der Spitze sitzt, welche Leute und Ratgeber man sich holt. Diese Wahl hat man ja auch, das heißt, man muss nicht alles wissen, aber man muss sich wenigstens die richtigen Leute besuchen, die einem dann helfen bei den Entscheidungen.
Nicole hat dafür das Kanzleramt ausbauen lassen, dass er am Amtsantritt, weil er hat seine gesamte Truppe mitgebracht und hat dann einfach den Laden übernommen.
Ja, also die Ideen mit den Spezialisten finde ich sehr gut. Ich sehe halt nur, in vielen Ländern und auch bei uns und auch bei euch muss ich sagen sehr oft, dass da zuerst einmal parteipolitische Maßstäbe angelegt werden und dann erst die Lücken mit Spezialisten gefüllt werden, die halt einer kennt und der weiß und der liegt eh auf der Linie. Er ist ein bisschen komisch, er ist ein Wissenschaftler, aber der wird schon mitmachen.
Die Probleme, sieht man ja jetzt auch, treten immer dann auf, wenn wirklich die Leute zu lange sich diesen schwierigen Aufgaben stellen müssen. Also ich sage mal, eigentlich stelle ich mir fünf Jahre als Kanzler eigentlich mehr als genug vor. Also wenn man in fünf Jahren Kanzler war, ist man glaube ich einfach durch. Und nach 17 Jahren ist man glaube ich dann nur noch daneben. Komplett. Und man sieht es jetzt überall in Nordrhein-Westfalen, wo die Dinge hochkochen. Also das ist sicherlich auch grundsätzlich ungesund. Heute war ja auch einiges aus Österreich an News hier in den Medien.
Ja ja, wir machen in ganz Europa wirbel fürchterlich momentan.
Und wie einigt ihr euch da gerade?
Naja, wenn ich mich so umhör im Bekanntenkreis, ist keiner mit der Entwicklung glücklich. Weil eigentlich hat man doch gehofft, es geht weiter mit Rot-Schwarz. Dass jetzt auf einmal da Blau-Schwarz am Horizont steht, ist, sag ich einmal, zumindest in meinem Bekanntenkreis eigentlich eher befremdlich.
Ich habe heute ein paar Zeitungskommentare gelesen, da haben einige das echt so gewertet, als ob diese neue Regierung mit Heider-Beteiligung irgendwie so ein heilsamer Neuanfang sein könnte, dass die rot-schwarze Koalition endlich mal zu Ende geht, finde ich eigentlich ziemlich gefährlich, so eine Überlegung irgendwie. Ich weiß nicht, wie du das siehst.
Naja, es ist eigentlich bei uns eher so die Stimmung, um Gottes Willen, so haben wir es aber nicht gemeldet. Weil die FPÖ ist in den letzten Wahlkampf eigentlich mit eher linken Themen gegangen. Das heißt, sie haben sehr soziale Standpunkte vertreten und eigentlich von rechts war abgesehen von ein paar Plakaten, die irgendwo offensichtlich durch die BR Kontrolle durchgerutscht sind bei der Partei, nichts zu sehen. Und ja, von denen haben sie halt ein paar Leute überzeugen lassen, die gesagt haben, naja, er ist ja eh nicht so arg und eigentlich hat er Recht, weil zufrieden bin ich nicht mit der rot-schwarzen Koalition, weil es geht ja nichts weiter und keiner hat gesehen, dass uns eigentlich verdammt gut geht.
Also ich muss sagen, meine Meinung ist so, nun das, was der Heider von sich gibt und den Typen kann ich nun auch nicht besonders leiden, aber auf der anderen Seite finde ich das schon ganz in Ordnung. Wie gesagt, das ist halt Demokratie, und um da nochmal so einen netten Spruch zu kolportieren, also auch die Demokratie kann nicht verhindern, dass Idioten an die Macht kommen, aber man braucht wenigstens nicht zur Waffe zu greifen, um sie da wieder wegzukriegen.
Ja, wäre noch die Frage, was man sich in Wien vielleicht so versiv überlegt für eine neue Regierung. Habt ihr da schon ein paar Ideen?
Nein, also kann ich nicht sagen, wüsste ich nicht, weil ich erlebe die Politik bei uns, aber beteilige mich nicht sonderlich aktiv daran.
Das tut ja in Deutschland eigentlich auch keiner, aber jetzt, wo die Geldkörper etwas zu offensichtlich geworden sind...
Einen Vorteil hat der Blau-Schwarz, nämlich der Kohl kann dann bei euch Asyl suchen und kann dann am Wolfgangsee wohnen, unbehelligt.
Ja, wenn man auf der anderen Seite, dann war der Kohl wirklich so schlecht.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Meine persönliche Meinung, ja.
Der Typ ähnelt einfach meinem Großvater, sowohl äußerlich als auch von dem, was er von sich gibt. Und wenn er auch nur, also wenn die Parallelen auch noch weitergehen, was jetzt der Fall zu sein scheint, dann traue ich ihm noch ganz andere Dinge zu, die viel schlimmer sind als alles, worüber im Augenblick spekuliert worden ist und alles, was man sich vorstellen kann.
Na gut, aber was man über Kohl tatsächlich sagen kann, ist ja, dass die Schwerpunkte der Politik waren eben nicht, daran irgendwie eine sinnvolle Gesellschaft zu erschaffen, sondern im Grunde genommen das, was die Wirtschaft fordert, auch ein Stück weit entgegen zu liefern. Also das Regierungstum ist vom Staatsmodell dazu verkommen, irgendwie Bedingungen zu schaffen, in der Wirtschaft irgendwie florieren kann.
Ich sage mal Tschüss nach Wien, schön, dass du angerufen hast. Es rufen jetzt ganz viele Leute an. Ich wollte lieber nochmal jemand anders. Es geht gerade das Telefon. Ah, hier ist Sabine.
Ich möchte mich mit dem Vorredner anschließen. Er hat völlig recht. Wenn man die Masse entscheiden lässt, hat man bei speziellen Themen immer das Problem, dass die Kenntnis des gesamten Problems nicht vorhanden ist. Weil du kannst den Leuten einfache Parolen mitgeben und sie übers Gefühl ansprechen. Das wirkt in den meisten Fällen auch. Das siehst du jetzt in Österreich. Da hat der Heider mit einfachen Parolen, soziale Sicherheit und was für die Leute tun und so, hat er wirklich Erfolg gehabt. In Deutschland ist es ähnlich. Wenn du immer guckst zu den Wahlen, da kommen Versprechen und Ankündigungen und so was. Und die Leute finden es gut, weil es einfach formuliert ist und unverständlich. Und was wirklich, wie komplex das ist, um sowas zu erreichen, was man da alles wissen muss. Das können die einzelnen Leute nicht überblicken. Im Nachhinein sehen sie dann, dass es doch nicht so einfach ist. Und die vergessen aber schnell wieder, dass es doch nicht so geht, wie es ihnen erklärt wurde.
Ja, aber was für der Lösungsansatz?
Der Lösungsansatz ist, dass man wirklich, nicht eine Monarchie, aber...
Eine Expertokratie sozusagen.
Nur in der Art, ja.
Im Internet gibt es etwas, das nennt sich Kompetenzhierarchie. Wenn man dir dieses RFC-Prinzip anguckt, diejenigen, die da letztendlich bestimmen, wo es lang geht, sind diejenigen, die sich am meisten engagieren und die aber auch die meisten Fachkenntnisse haben. Ansonsten können sie gar nicht mitdiskutieren. Die Frage ist, das ist nicht unbedingt demokratisch. Das muss man dazu sagen.
Erzähl mal kurz, RFC, was das heißt.
Also RFC, im Internet funktioniert das so. Als allererstes kommt ein Request for Comments, also einen Vorschlag mit der Bitte um Kommentierung. Und daraus wird dann möglicherweise sozusagen eine Entscheidungsfindung, ein Voting mit dem Ziel, dann tatsächlich eine Empfehlung. RFC heißt dann schlussendlich bei dem, was dabei rauskommt, gilt, solange jemand was besserem einfällt. Und also davor kommt ein Call for Paper.
Es gibt, glaube ich, mittlerweile über 2000 RFCs, ne?
Ja, weit aus mehr. Jaja, irgendwas 3000 in dem Bereich.
Was sind die Gesetze?
Das sind sozusagen die Gesetze. Ich meine, man könnte das ja mal ausprobieren, jetzt RFCs. Es gibt auch schon RFCs für die allerunmöglichsten Themen. Irgendwie, wie man irgendwie IP-Nummern, mit Welcherklammern vergibbelt und auch so Dinge, die eigentlich mit dem Internet nichts zu tun haben.
Ja, der JRP.
Genau, vorzugsweise am 1. April kommen dann so Dinge wie das Joint Rolling Protocol und dies und das. Also man könnte natürlich auch einfach mal anfangen, RFCs für gesellschaftliche Themen zu entwickeln.
Das Problem ist doch, dass die gesellschaftlichen Kompetenzen nicht im Internet sind. Im Internet sind technische Kompetenzen und informatische und technische Kompetenzen für Geräte, die ihre eigenen Interessen haben.
Das würde ich jetzt aber echt nicht sagen. Also es gibt genug politische Gruppen im Netzen, da geht es vielleicht nicht mehr um.
Lass uns noch fünf Jahre warten. Wie gesagt, es kommt jetzt leider fünf Jahre zu früh, dass sich irgendwie dieses System jetzt auflöst.
Ja, das wurde von anderen Systemen auch gesagt. Man hat gesagt, das Fernsehgerät bringt den Leuten Informationen aus aller Welt, dass sie sich ein Bild machen können über die Objektivität, über die Verhältnisse, die herrschen. Und daraus ihre eigene Anschauung entwickeln können. Und dadurch, dass die Leute die Fakten und die Tatsachen nicht über den Verstand verarbeiten, sondern über das Gefühl, kommen also praktisch keine verwertbaren Erkenntnisse dabei raus. Und das ist auch beim Internet das Problem, denn du musst ja mal gucken, was wirklich für Informationen angeboten wären.
Ich meine, was heißt angeboten? Ich meine, wenn du im Internet suchst irgendwie, dann findest du auch die berühmten Nu-Gets im Schlamm so. Ich will ja gar nicht abstreiten, dass es keine Menge Schlamm gibt. Aber noch mal ganz kurz auf deine Gefühlstheorie, die ich gar nicht uninteressant finde. Was meinst du denn, ist im Moment das Gefühl des gemeinen Bürgers, also des ganz normalen Bürgers über Politik, also kotzen die Leute denn nur noch, oder an welchem Status sind die denn angelangt, wenn das tatsächlich eine gefühlsmäßige Interpretation ist?
Sie sind an dem Status angekommen, dass diese Vorgänge, die jetzt veröffentlicht werden, die bekannt wären, dass wir die wahrnehmen und in so einer Art Sensationshunger, oder man könnte auch sagen, wie auf der Autobahn die Gaffer. Die schauen gebannt auf diese Vorgänge, können sich eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen, wie sich das entwickeln konnte.
Schadensfreude ist ein psychologischer Mechanismus, der zum Beispiel auch bei Horrorfilmen hinzukommt, genauso wie bei Autobahnenunfällen. Hier geht es eben besser als das, was du anguckst. Das ist ein gutes Gefühl.
Ja, genau. Im Prinzip würden die Leute wirklich mal nachdenken. Würden sie doch sehen, dass das verurteilte steuerbetrüger Parteivorsitzende waren. Die Leute ziehen keine Konsequenzen aus. Die sehen den Vorgang getrennt von allem anderen als eine Art Sensation.
Was kommt bei dir an Gefühlen auf?
Nicht an Gefühlen, sondern ich überlege mir, was ist eigentlich das Ziel dieses Regierungssystems, das sich parlamentarische Demokratie nennt. Das vorrangige Ziel scheint mir, in dem Parteiensystem zu sein, die Macht zu halten. Und zwar geht es denen nicht darum, jetzt noch eine Million oder da noch ein paar Millionen zu holen. Geld haben die genug, die bekommen auch genug. Sondern das Ziel ist, wirklich Macht auszuüben, um ihre Position zu feststellen.
Das heißt, du siehst das rein sachlich funktional, die Geschichte?
Naja, die hat doch eine bestimmte Funktion, diese parlamentarische Demokratie.
Und, findest du das gut oder bist du sauer?
Also persönlich habe ich keine Nachteile dadurch. Deswegen bin ich auch nicht sauer.
Naja, Moment, du weißt ja noch nicht, welche Nachteile dir dadurch entstanden sind, wie viele Steuergelder oder wie viele Arbeitsplätze oder welchen gesellschaftlichen Wert diese Leunascheiße gehabt hätte oder welchen Wert es gehabt hätte, nicht irgendwelche Panzer zu liefern vielleicht?
Ja, das sind doch nicht Kleinigkeiten, aber das ist doch nicht die Masse. Überleg mal, was aus der Wertschöpfung, die wirklich vorhanden ist, was nachher alles bezahlt wird, was da alles mitgeschleift wird. Da sind doch diese Summen bei Leuna und jetzt die Kofferträgerei, die sind doch wirklich nicht relevant.
Peanuts sozusagen.
Nein, Peanuts sag ich nicht.
Nein, okay, aber die sind vernachlässigt.
Erdnussfarben. Die haben keine relevante Größe.
Und so beschissen fühlst du dich auch nicht? Nein, beschissen nicht.
Dann überlege mal, wie gut es mir geht, dass ich praktisch machen kann, was ich will, dass ich versorgt bin, dass ich relative Sicherheit habe und so. Da geht es anderen Leuten wirklich sehr viel schlechter.
Ich meine, dass in der...
Dann traue ich dir ein paar Millionen nicht hinterher.
Also du meinst, das ist einfach der Preis der Freiheit.
Sehr gute These. Und das kannst du nicht widerlegen. Die ist super, die These. Ich bin eigentlich auch so drauf. Also ich würde nicht dafür auf die Straße gehen jetzt.
Ganz genau, ja. Nicht.
Ja, ja, ich meine, es war alles böse und schlecht.
Ich wüsste nicht, was ich auf der Straße sollte, außer zu frieren.
Ich finde nur die Auffassung, dass, wenn du immer sagst, die Leute sehen das so und so und ich verstehe das nicht richtig, das finde ich elitär. Also es klingt so, als ob du da der Einzige bist oder die Leute, die hier reden oder so, die Einzigen sind, die es verstehen. Ich glaube das absolut gar nicht. Ich glaube, dass die allermeisten Leute sehr gut verstehen, was da passiert, dass die nur ganz unterschiedliche Schlüsse für sich da ausziehen. Resignation oder die wollen gar nichts mehr davon wissen oder sie wollten noch nie was davon wissen oder so. Wenn du dich mal genauer umhörst, wenn du wirklich mal genauer als Reporter zum Beispiel mit Leuten über sowas redest, dann merkst du, dass die das sehr, sehr gut verstehen. Und die sind auch nicht alle verblödert durchs Fernsehen. Die wissen auch, was beim Fernsehen mit ihnen passiert, weil sie fühlen sich schlecht nach drei Stunden vor der Glotze.
Also es gibt sehr viele Leute, die begeistert sind von Fernsehprogrammen und so.
Also im Moment, treibt dir das nicht die Tränen in die Augen oder steigt da nicht irgendwo Wut auf, wenn du siehst, wie da eine Partei eigentlich intelligente Leute, wie die sich hinstellen und entweder irgendwie kackfrech mit dem Finger auf andere zeigen?
Du unterscheidest jetzt zwischen zwei Instanzen, du unterscheidest zwischen Moral und dem täglichen Leben. Also das heißt, in unserem täglichen Leben bewegt uns das jetzt nicht groß. Wir verfolgen das mit Interesse, wie vielleicht die Gaffer an der Autobahn. Wir empfinden einen Schauder irgendwie, so einen leichten Schauder und so ein leichtes Kitzeln und sagen, naja, mal gucken, was passiert. Ist ja spannend, da lese ich jeden Tag irgendwie die Zeit.
Ich glaube, du unterschätzt noch den Anteil derjenigen, die sagen, diese dreckigen kleinen Scheiße haben sich erwischen lassen. Die haben sich einfach erwischen lassen. Die waren nicht geschickt genug. Und wenn ich das machen werde, ich das geschickter machen. Ich glaube, eine Menge Leute, die empören das gar nicht so sehr, sondern die lesen einfach die Zeitung und sagen, wie unprofessionell. Und das ist auch das, was mich im Moment ein bisschen daran erstaunt. Also die Dreistigkeit, mit der da vorgegangen wird, die Dreistigkeit, mit der der CDU sagt, etwaige rein rechnerisch aus dem Gesetz ergebende 40 Millionen Forderungen, die werden sie nicht bezahlen, sie werden irgendwie 6 Millionen zahlen und alles andere können sich in den Finger stecken. So diese Dreistigkeit, die ist einfach... Also das ist das, was mich ein bisschen stört. Und wo ich ein bisschen erstaunt bin, dass du das jetzt, Entschuldigung, an den Hörer gerichtet, dass du das ganz so emotional freisiehst und sagst, naja, so ist es halt.
Ja, überlege mal, wenn du jetzt eine Volksabstimmung machst, meinetwegen kannst du die auch über die Netze machen oder so.
Über was auch immer.
Was meinst du, was da für ein Ergebnis rauskommt, jetzt kurz nachdem die Vorgänge veröffentlicht wurden?
Na, ich glaube nicht, der Schröder hat dadurch beliebter geworden.
Nee, der Schröder ist doch in dem gleichen System mit.
Ja, eben, das ist ja gut. Was würdest du denn sagen, was soll da rauskommen? Ich meine, was willst die Leute fragen? Findest du das alles scheiße?
Ich kann mich auch ein bisschen an diese Ausländerunterschriftenaktion von der CDU. Da wurden die Leute auch kopfscheu mitgemacht und ein großer Teil hat unterschrieben und so.
Noch finanziert aus dem Koffergeld?
Weil die Leute nämlich gesehen haben, Au, Ausländer, das könnte gefährlich werden und so. Und die haben gar nicht lange überlegt, was mit der Aktion eigentlich bezweckt werden soll. Sondern die haben sich dadurch, dass das Thema angesprochen wurde, in der Art, dass ihnen Angst gemacht wurde.
Ja, aber genau das ist auch mein Eindruck, dass diese Regierung Kohl systematisch das Bildungswesen flach gelegt hat, die Existenzängste verstärkt hat und genau auf diese Angst basiert hat. Sie haben irgendwie ihre Machtspielchen drüber gespielt. Also dass einfach eine Großteil der Bevölkerung Schiere Angst hat und deswegen auch nicht sagt, wir müssen das jetzt anders machen, sondern solange jeder einzelne seine Ruhe hat und nicht Ärger kriegt, ist okay.
Andi, ich geh noch mal ans Telefon. Guten Abend, wer bist du?
Ja, ich war heute in Potsdam. 20.000 Menschen auf einem Platz, ist faszinierend. Das ging um die Sparmaßnahmen bei den Kitaeinrichtungen. Habt ihr das nicht gelesen in der Zeitung? Doch.
Das ist ja auch wunderbar.
Leider war kein Politiker da.
Keiner. Das ist nicht viel.
Nee, keiner. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, das ist beschämend.
Aber vielleicht kommen wir auch anmöglich ohne Politiker klar. Ich meine, kannst du sagen, schade, dass sie nicht da sind und dass sie das nicht wahrnehmen auf der anderen Seite?
Wenn wir endlich erkennen, dass unsere Erde allen gehört, dass wir keine Grenzen brauchen, keine Waffen und würde ich sagen, dass wir uns gut verstehen und endlich erkennen, dass unsere Stimmmänner dazu da sind, um Probleme zu lösen, nämlich unsere Sprache.
Leider ist den Leuten die Sprache nicht mehr gegeben. Das ist ein großes Problem. Weil durch die Medien verlernen die Menschen zu sprechen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich auch durch den Computer. Die Kommunikation fällt unter den Tisch total.
Naja, das will ich nicht sagen.
Also was wir da machen vor unseren Computern, die sind ja vernetzt und wir behaupten ja immer, dass wir da Kommunikationsnetze benutzen.
Soll ich euch mal ein schräne Ding erzählen von dem Computer? Also ich hatte eine alte Nenntante, die war über 80. Und die hatte einen Antrag. Ich wollte einen Antrag stellen. Und zwar ging es um die Rente ihres vermissten Mannes. Da haben wir ihr geholfen bei. Und da hat sie plötzlich Post bekommen aus Berlin. Es war ja ein Snackisch und zwar nicht an ihre Person gerichtet, sondern an ihren vermissten Mann direkt adressiert. Und es wurde darin gebeten darum, dass er, wenn er seine Rente beantragt, bitte schön seine Rentennummer angeben möchte. Und das kam von Berlin und da habe ich angerufen. Da hat man mir gesagt, da hat der Computer irgendwas nicht richtig gemacht. Und da habe ich gesagt, der wurde aber irgendwie gespeichert durch eine Menschenhand. Die Frau, die halt beiden Herrscher gekriegt hat, die hat nun gedacht, die Rente wird genehmigt irgendwie von ihrem vermissten Mann. Und plötzlich kriegt der jetzt, der gar nicht mehr da ist, Post. Er möchte seine Rentennummer angeben, wenn er Rente beantragt.
Na gut, das ist aber die Abteilung Shit Happens. Also das ist jetzt nicht, glaube ich, so ganz das Thema. Ich meine, dass Computer irgendwie auch Scheiße machen, genauso wie Menschen.
Die Frage ist doch, wenn wir reingehen in die Netze, wir können uns natürlich informieren. Dann ist einfach die Frage, was wir da lesen. Das heißt, wer das Informationsmonopol hat, erzählt uns, was Sache ist. Also so einfach ist es nicht mit dem freien Zugang zu Informationen.
Ja, und dass die Medien dazu führen, dass wir nicht mehr miteinander sprechen, das finde ich ziemlich platt.
Tut mir leid, aber das ist einfach Käse.
Ich meine das auch anders. Ich habe da ganz viele Sachen zusammengenommen. Meiner Ansicht nach ist es einfach so, dass viele Kinder heute nicht mehr so richtig lernen, draußen zu spielen, sondern sie sitzen immer mehr drin an den Computern. Und sie verlieren dadurch irgendwie soziale Eigenschaften und gewinnen eher praktische Eigenschaften.
Ja, aber das kommt nicht, weil die vom Computer sitzen, sondern das kommt daher, dass sie von ihren Eltern vor dem Fernseher und vom Computer geparkt werden und dass sie mit den Kindern nicht mehr genug sprechen, weil dadurch lernst du das ja nur als Kind.
Das sind die Eltern schuld, die Medien schuld. Was ich einfach sage ist, dass viele Leute einfach keine Sprache mehr haben. Bei Orwell nennt man das New Speak. Es gibt immer weniger Worte. Du sagst irgendwie nicht mehr something is ugly, du sagst it's double ungood. Also das heißt keine Gefühlswertung mehr, sondern nur noch irgendwie Wiederholung. Und dadurch lernen die Leute zu fühlen. Also das ist eines der Orwell Szenarien.
Wollen wir nicht noch mal Musik spielen?
Und auch ein Hörer reinnehmen.
Das rufen gerade ganz viele an.
Hier ist Crispi, ein heiler Irres-Hessner.
Und zwar wollte ich gerade nochmal das Orwell Szenario darstellen. Das Problem ist einfach wieder, dass beim Internet das gleiche passieren kann wie beim Fernsehen oder an den anderen Medien. Und dass eine Art Monopolisierung einsetzt, wie die Jungs vom CCC schon sagten, dass der, der dir die Information rausgibt, der hat eben sozusagen die Macht nicht.
Ja und?
Naja, es ist einfach das Problem, ich sehe es ja jeden Tag, wenn ich im Internet bin, dass, ich weiß nicht, da...
Die Konzentration, die stattfindet einfach und ja...
Na gut, aber ich kann mir im Internet ja meine Informationsrealitäten aussuchen.
Ja, das meine ich. Das Gute am Internet ist einfach, dass man ganz schnell einen Kanal wechselt. Es ist nicht wie beim Fernsehen. Man ist da angewiesen auf die und die Informationskanäle. Da muss man sich einfach aussuchen. Man hat Millionen, Milliarden Möglichkeiten. Man kann einfach wegschalten. Also eine Art Internet-Zapping, sage ich mal.
Ja, aber die Frage ist ja, können wir das bei gesellschaftlichen Konflikten genauso tun? Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass wenn es den Bach runtergeht oder wenn es hier und da irgendwie eng wird, ja, es gibt ja schon einen Großteil der Bevölkerung, denen interessiert das dann einfach nicht mehr. Der hat dann die Möglichkeit, mithilfe der Medien wegzuzappen oder sich eben nur noch mit ihrem Spezialthema, sei das jetzt DCP, IP, Fußball, Goldfischzucht oder Haschischrauchen, irgendwie zu beschäftigen und dann einfach alles andere zu verdrängen. Also ist nicht nur ein Vorteil, was du da gerade schilderst, glaube ich.
Jungs, eins muss ich ja mal sagen, die Musik, die ihr mitgebracht habt, die ist richtig krass. Ich hatte eben stundenlang so ein ESO gedudel da drunter. Das war von hier an.
Konsequenz. Nordrhein-Westfalens Ministerpräsident Clement SPD hat den Rücktritt von Finanzminister Schleuser bedauert. Schleuser sei einer der angesehensten Finanzpolitiker der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, sagte Clement. Der ehemalige Finanzminister werde ihm auch in Zukunft zur Seite stehen, fügte der Ministerpräsident an. Ablehnung. Die britische Regierung hat Forderungen nach neuen Gutachten über den Gesundheitszustand des chilenischen Ex-Diktators Pinochet zurückgewiesen. Bei einer Anhörung vor dem obersten Gerichtshof in London, sagte der Anwalt von Innenminister Straw, diese habe nicht die Macht, Pinochet zu weiteren Untersuchungen zu zwingen. Rotstift. Rund 20.000 Menschen haben heute vor dem Landtag in Potsdam gegen die geplanten Streichungen im Kita-Bereich protestiert. Die Brandenburger Koalition will die Zuschüsse für Kindertagesstätten in diesem und im nächsten Jahr um 93 Millionen nah kürzen. Vorwurf. Die Hilfsorganisation für politische Opfer HELP hat gegen den Regisseur des Films Sonnenallee, Leander Hausmann, Strafanzeige gestellt. Sie wirft ihm Beleidigung der Maueropfer vor. Sonnenallee war mit über zwei Millionen Kinobesuchern der erfolgreichste deutsche Spielfilm im vergangenen Jahr. Basketball in der Bundesliga hat Alba gegen Braunschweig mit 85 zu 61 gewonnen. Alba bleibt damit an der Tabellenspitze. Wette. Nachts zeitweise Regen, ein bis drei Grad am Tag ebenfalls. Leichter Regen zwei bis fünf Grad.
Nur 32 ist es jetzt und das war das Fütz Kurzinfo mit Falk Ziegler. Chaosradio geht in die letzte Runde. Welche Nummer war das? 8? 5. Okay, wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit hier, um weiter zu sprechen über alles, was uns bisher beschäftigt hat. Und die Nummer dazu ist 03317779110. In der Studie sind Andi, Pavel und Martin vom CCC und ich bin Sabine. Das war ja richtige Popmusik mal zwischendurch.
Der Weltrevolutionsrat hört, der Hörer redet.
Der Hörer redet?
War der nicht eben noch dran?
Ja, wer bist du?
Das ist ja Blödsinn. Will kein Wasserkarnickel. Hi, wer bist du?
Hallo Sabine.
Hallo, Fabel.
Und zwar, als vorhin George Orwell kam oder angesprochen wurde, ist mir noch eingefallen. Ich meine, ich habe auch eine Frage. Ich meine, André, Fabel, Sabine, ich meine, so ein Szenario wie bei 1984, ich meine, ist es möglich oder meint ihr, dass es schon in gewisser Weise passiert ist? So eine Sache.
Auf jeden Fall.
Mit der 80er Jahre ist es passiert.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das hat gerade angefangen und ich kann dir ausahmen, wann, und das war ungefähr letzte Woche. Da war nämlich erstmals im Radio die Rede von der organisierten Rückführung der Kosovo-Albaner. Vor einem halben Jahr hätte man dazu noch Abschiebung gesagt. Dann reden wir auch nicht mehr von Überwachungsstaat, das ist ganz klar, sondern wir reden von einem Staat, der den Sicherheitsbedürfnissen des Bürgers Rechnung trägt.
Das ist aber die alte Diskussion Atomkraft oder Kernkraft. Weil Atomkraft war halt wegen der Bombe irgendwie daneben. Ja, aber zu Orwell, zu 1984, das Ding heißt ja so wegen 1948. Das hat es alles schon mal in viel schlimmerer Form gegeben, als es zum Glück hier ist. Aber es ist nicht ausgeschlossen, dass es nicht wieder ganz dicke kommt, wenn wir nicht alle aufpassen. Und das, was im Moment abläuft, also...
Das Problem mit dem Aufpassen ist eben so eine Sache. Ich meine, die meisten Leute, die haben einfach verlernt aufzupassen. Also ich denke mal, die Leute, so wie ihr meint, wie sich echt noch die ganzen Informationen aufsaugen, wie ein trockener Schwamm und die auch wieder verarbeiten. Also die Leute entweder, entweder prallt das bei den Informationen ab oder die nehmen sie schon auf, aber die verarbeiten sie einfach nicht weiter. Das ist das Hauptproblem bei der ganzen Sache.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass die Leute das alles nicht verstehen.
Ja, aber die resignieren einfach.
Ja, das kann sein.
Und deswegen sind wir wahrscheinlich auch, ich meine, wir hatten ja irgendwie die Hoffnung, dass wir hier so ein bisschen Eckpunkte für ein neues Betriebssystem sammeln können. Da steht noch nicht so schrecklich viel auf dem Zettel.
Ich habe letztens erst was gelesen, ein gewisser Skinner, ach, schon ein bisschen älter. Der hat auch so eine Vision, eine Art Utopia, aber es ging mal von auch mal die Frage um Geld, ob Geld noch nötig ist. Der hat das ganz interessante Ansatz eigentlich. Also man hat bezahlt pro Jahr einen bestimmten Kredit, oder das wird einem vom Lohn abgezogen, was man pro Tag kriegt. Und dafür, für diesen Betrag hat man eben bestimmte Dienstleistungen, im öffentlichen Leben und auch bestimmte Grundnahrungsmittel und so eine Sache eben. Bloß das Problem einfach, das sind die ganzen alten Sachen, einfach alles, das ganze System oder Systeme sind zu konsolidativ. Da müsste irgendwas passieren, irgendein Bruch in der ganzen Sache.
Also ich nehme jetzt mal als Anregung auf in die Liste der Eckpunkte für die anzustrebenden revolutionären Umwälzungen. Ich denke, es geht nicht nur darum, dass hier Infrastrukturmaßnahmen stehen, sondern dass es auch im Prinzip eine Grundrente gibt. Also das erste Mal, das Grobe muss geregelt sein. Ansonsten kannst du mit den Leuten eh nicht reden, weil wenn sie nichts zu fressen haben, dann sind sie zu sehr damit beschäftigt. Ja, dann fangen sie auch nicht an, die Sicherheit zu entwickeln, überhaupt mal zu fragen, ob da oben irgendwas schief läuft.
Aber dann reden sie auch nicht, das willst du doch nicht.
Ja, okay, das wollen wir.
Dass sie reden?
Wir wollen, dass sie reden, ja.
Bist du ja sicher?
Den nächsten. Sammeln wir noch Punkte fürs Betriebssystem? Hallo, wer bist du? Hallo Robert.
Ja, ich wollte mal so ein bisschen was sagen hierzu. Na hier, also Jugendliche in der Gesellschaft haben ja am wenigsten Chancen.
Ist das so? Nö, die haben die meisten Chancen. Die sind noch lernfähig.
Naja, im Parlament sitzen zum Beispiel mehr die alten Leute.
Also wenn du meinst, dass Jugendliche keine Chancen haben, dann hast du meine Oma im Altenheim noch nicht gesehen, weil die noch für geile Chancen hat.
Na bei uns, also ich komme aus Narswerde, aus Sachsen. Und bei uns ist zum Beispiel in der Stadt so, dass die ganzen Stadtväter, also alles älter sind. Und alle sagen, dass sie um die Jugendlichen kümmern. Aber am Ende fängt es, sitzen wir alle auf der Straße, bei uns machen alles zu. Und der Bürgermeister geht halt zu alten Leutchen ins Haus und Kaffee trinken und so eine Sachen.
Gut, aber da kannst du ja in 20 Jahren dich dann dran rächen.
Nee, er kann jetzt einen Vorschlag für das Betriebssystem machen.
Was ist deine Forderung? Was würdest du der Jugend geben wollen?
Naja, mehr Mitbestimmung ist recht. Zum Beispiel, man darf ja erst wählen und mitbestimmen, wenn man 18 ist.
Genau, Wahlrecht ab Null Jahre wäre, glaube ich.
Null Jahre? Ja, aber dann hast du erst mal irgendwie nur die Entscheidung Pampers oder diese anderen.
Wieso, ist doch Mitbestimmung.
Das würde schon mal, glaube ich, ein bisschen was verändern und verschieben.
Danke dir.
Das ist doch prima.
So geht das.
Noch mal? Nee, tut mir leid. Tut mir echt leid. Aber jetzt rufen so viele Leute an. Da muss man einfach etwas andere auch ranlassen. Hallo, wer bist du?
Hallo, Flo. Hallo. Bin ich bei Fritzradio?
Was ist dein Eckpunkt?
Mein erster Punkt.
Also wir sind hier gerade dabei. Eckpunkte für das neue Betriebssystem der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Ja, keine Ahnung, ich hatte vorhin auf dem Rückweg...
Keine Ahnung, war bereits eine Antwort. Danke schön.
Keine Ahnung?
Nein, keine Ahnung.
Ja, hallo, ich muss das Radio mal leiser machen. Ja, und zwar, ihr habt gerade über die Eckpunkte geredet und über die Zukunft, die wahrscheinlich der Bundesrepublik bevorsteht, denke ich mal. Und zwar, mich hat in letzter Zeit, ich habe in letzter Zeit ziemlich viel erfahren und ziemlich viele Informationen bekommen, muss mich deshalb auch ziemlich zurückhalten. Und ja, ich finde, die Eckpunkte der Bundesrepublik Deutschland werden in nächster Zeit auf jeden Fall die Arten der Kommunikation sein, spezifisch auf die künstliche Intelligenz.
Was soll das denn sein?
Die Eckpunkte?
Nee, das verstehen wir nicht. Mach mal Klartext.
Also, Klartext. Mach mal reden Klartext, Mann.
Also, in nächster Zeit wird viel passieren im Computer Sektor, ganz grob erklärt.
Das wissen wir auch, Mann. Was ist die Killer-Applikation? Was ist der Eckpunkt?
Der Eckpunkt ist einfach, dass die grobe Bevölkerung, ich rede von der groben Bevölkerung, die sich nicht weiter mit den Informationsdrangen der heutigen Nachrichtenwelt beschäftigt.
Okay, genug Klattytüten. Nächster, bitte.
Grobe irgendwas. Was muss man nehmen, um so drauf zu sein? Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Neben euch will ich echt nichts haben.
Wer bist du?
Ich bin Karsten.
Hallo, Karsten.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das genau ein Eckpunkt ist, aber ich frage mich, warum ihr euch aufregt.
Letztendlich hat das Ganze ja sowieso ein System für sich entwickelt.
Cool, Welt aufnehmen, nicht aufregen, das ist absolut wichtig.
Ich bin auch Aquasasi.
Ich glaube, mich möchte ich hier ärgert freuen, muss ich sagen.
Weil das ist nicht unbedingt blöd, dass ich überrascht gewesen bin.
Dann habe ich was anderes gesagt.
Man muss sich ja nicht alles anhören, was dann so an Witzen kommt. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Hallo, hier ist Sabine.
Ich höre es nochmal, ihr habt mich gerade rausgeschmissen, weil ich keine Ahnung gesagt habe. Ich wollte das ganz schnell zurücknehmen und schnell einen Eckpunkt anführen. Und zwar, ich hatte vorhin die Diskussion gehört über diese Problematik mit der Gelduntreue und so weiter in der Politik. Ich finde die Diskussion, die daran angeschlossen hat, bezüglich der öffentlichen Meinung dazu sehr interessant. Vorhin wurde gesagt, dass es möglicherweise elitär wäre, der Gedanke, dass die Menschen damit sich nicht auseinandersetzen.
Ich bin davon überzeugt, dass sie das tun.
Aber die sind einfach so sehr beschäftigt mit ihren Alltäglichkeiten, wie jeder von uns beschäftigt ist, mit seinem täglichen Broterwerb. Entlastung von Existenzängsten, das ist auf jeden Fall ein guter Punkt.
In der DDR musste man sich zwar über alles mögliche Sorgen machen, unter anderem irgendwie, was man ausspricht und dies und das. Aber ich glaube, die Leute hatten ein bisschen weniger Existenzangst, weil irgendwie Wohnung und Happy Happy war geregelt. Das heißt nicht, dass es besser war, aber zumindest in diesem Punkt.
Ich glaube auch gar nicht, dass es ein Problem ist. Ich glaube so, dass das alltägliche Leben der Menschen das für jeden Menschen wichtigste ist. Und dass die Menschen eigentlich sie möglicherweise auch gar nicht damit beschäftigen wollen, dass sie das auch gar nicht können.
Ach, das gibt ja schon eine Menge, die das wollen. Also ich meine, nicht alle, aber...
Ja, ich finde, dass es einfach sehr normal ist. Und das ist, glaube ich, deshalb auch zu keiner Meinung.
Politik ist pervers.
Nee, das wäre vielleicht wieder ein Appell zur Regionalisierung. Also dass man nicht so einen großen Bereich überblicken muss, um damit zu bestimmen, sondern dass du einen kleineren Bereich hast. Also vielleicht ist das so was in die Richtung.
Ich glaube einfach, dass die Leute, also dass die Politik und Wirtschaft und die Abhängigkeit der Politik zur Wirtschaft sehr groß ist. Und ich glaube auch, dass es falsch anzunehmen wäre, dass die heutigen Politiker oder wie es auch immer schon wagt, denke ich mal, nicht unbedingt das Interesse des Volkes wirklich als oberste Priorität ansehen, sondern dass es einfach wirklich eine wirtschaftliche Verstrickung gibt, die einfach nicht von der Hand zu weisen ist. Und dass in solchen Sachen, in solchen kleinen Fauxpas, die da passieren, einfach der Öffentlichkeit mal bewusst wird, wie es vielleicht in Staaten schon längst Uses ist, dass eben die Wirtschaft ein großes Mitspracherecht hat und dass sehr viel transparenter gehandhabt wird als in Deutschland.
Und was wäre für dich eine bessere Art und Weise?
Für mich wäre es, glaube ich mal, also ich gehe einmal davon aus, dass die Menschen wirklich so sind, wie sie nun mal sind. Und ich finde es deshalb auch nicht elitär, sondern ich finde es einfach vielleicht ein bisschen quergedacht und vielleicht auch sie selbst im Weg gestanden, wenn man daran irgendwas ändern möchte an dem System.
Naja, kleinere Communities vielleicht, dass du mehr Überblick hast und dass du direkter an Entscheidungen, die dich betreffen, beteiligt bist.
Möglicherweise oder einfach vielleicht einfach, dass die Menschen in der Bevölkerung einfach...
Du möchtest was ändern, wenn dich was nervt. Ich möchte was ändern, wenn mich was nervt. Und es gibt Dinge, die mich nerven. Gibt es Dinge, die dich nerven?
Auf jeden Fall. Und zwar nervt mich, und das ist der Eckpunkt, nervt mich, dass die Bevölkerung anscheinend so schockiert ist. Somit also beweist, dass sie sich mit diesem Thema gar nicht genug auseinandergesetzt hat, dass sie möglicherweise schockiert sein kann von sowas, was in der Politik schon immer so war und immer so sein wird. Dass sie jetzt auf einmal nur dadurch, dass es transparent geworden ist, und dass es durch die Medien publik gemacht worden ist.
Also du meinst, die Gesellschaft ist nicht realitätstauglich?
Doch, ich glaube schon, dass sie realitätstauglich ist. Ich glaube nur, dass die Tauglichkeit erzeugt werden muss, unterstützt werden muss, dass zum Beispiel solche Sendungen, wie sie jetzt laufen, dass ein öffentliches Forum sich damit beschäftigt, nicht um, das ist ja auch wieder der Widerspruch, dass die Leute sich nicht um halb eins oder um zwei dann beschäftigen.
Da müssen wir arbeiten.
Das ist das Ding, aber ich glaube auch, dass es einfach nicht das Forum bilden würde, weil die Leute einfach im Grunde genommen das Interesse daran haben, weil die Leute sich einfach mit anderen Dingen beschäftigen, mit Dingen, die durch diese Gesellschaft auch...
Ja, aber du wirst jetzt auch im Netz aktiv, wir haben Newscodes an, und das müsste ich nicht anderen Dingen, also insofern...
Aber das ist nicht der Gro der Menschen, die im Netz aktiv sind und sich solche Websites anschauen. Das ist es einfach nicht. Es gibt immer Leute, die sagen...
Ja, aber Website angucken wird auch nicht die Welt verändern.
Na ja, wenn sie sich durchlesen, was da steht, vielleicht schon.
Aber wer liest sich das denn durch?
Naja, das sehen wir in unseren Logs. Das sind gar nicht so wenig Leute und es werden auch immer mehr. Also das ist nicht von der Hand zu weisen, dass momentan eine Bewegung stattfindet, die vielleicht möglicherweise auch so etwas hinsteuert.
Ich finde es auch sehr gut, dass das gemacht wird, und ich finde es auch sehr wichtig, dass es gemacht wird. Im Internet sehe ich eine sehr große Chance, ein unabhängiges, also von irgendwelchen finanziellen, wirtschaftlichen Banden gelöstes Forum, dass ich damit beschäftigen kann, was einfach jeder auf eine relativ günstige Art und Weise Zugang dazu findet, wenn mal irgendwo in die Hürde genommen ist, diese technischen Hürden und so weiter. Das Verständnis ist...
Du, so entwickeln wir schon längst Software. Wir einigen uns mit anderen Usern auf der Welt darüber, wie wir Software schreiben und dann schreiben wir sie zusammen.
Okay, ich denke, die Eckpunkte haben wir drin. Wir können auch mal weitere saugen.
Danke für deinen Anruf.
Guten Abend. Meine neue Gesellschaft, die sollte auf alle Fälle nicht drücken und ziehen an mir, weil ich ja Mensch bin, der so auch alleine gehen kann. Ich möchte nicht in 5 Mark stehen vorgehalten werden, dem ich hinterherrennen muss, um überleben zu können. Ich möchte auch nicht einen Daumen auf den Rücken kriegen und gedrückt werden, damit ich weiter leben darf. Das sind die Punkte, die bei mir wichtig sind. Leider ist das einzige Haken jetzt daran, dass der Mensch selber ja irgendwie, wenn er zwar auch Interesse hat und Sachen weiterentwickelt, dass die Gesellschaft, ob die funktionieren würde, geht mir durch den Kopf. Und ein gewisser Druck ist einfach nötig. Das ist jetzt der Widerspruch an der Sache, dass man sagen muss, ich möchte gerne...
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das ein Widerspruch ist, weil du hast ja auch immer etwas, was ich als Produktivitätszwang oder was auch immer nennen könnte. Also irgendwie bist du einfach nicht glücklich, wenn du nicht was zu tun hast. Und sicherlich bist du glücklicher, wenn du in Ruhe ausschlafen kannst und wenn du nicht irgendwie etwas tun musst, sondern wenn du es tun kannst, wenn du tatsächlich die Möglichkeit hast, irgendwie produktiv zu sein, unter freien Bedingungen, nicht unter Existenzandsbedingungen. Insofern sehe ich da keinen Widerspruch und keinen Haken drin und nehme den Punkt einfach auf.
Das ist ein super Punkt.
Und zwar finde ich, ich will nur sagen, ein Eckpunkt. Und zwar wäre ich unheimlich dafür, dass einfach mal das Geld, das ich sonst teuernd zahle und so, dass ich da so ein kleines Mitbestimmungsrecht drüber habe. Ich meine, dass ich jetzt sagen kann, ich zahle 1000 Mark Steuern im Jahr und davon möchte ich jetzt, dass dann Gelder in irgendwelche Länder gepumpt werden für Staudämmig oder sonstiger Käse, dass ich da einfach ein Riegel vorsetzen kann, dass ich sage, nee, ich will das mein Geld jetzt für ein Heimzüge abfüllen.
Das ist ein guter Punkt. Das könnte man elektronisch auch machen, also keine Rüstungsausgaben dafür mehr Bildungswesen und so.
Genau, du hast so ein Fragebogen, da kannst du so ankreuzen.
Das wäre im Prinzip eine Volksabstimmung über den Staatshaushalt.
Ja, cool, okay, ist gebaut.
Der nächste bitte, der ist über am Arzt hier.
Hallo, Kalle.
Ich wollte sagen, dass mit dem Wahlrecht ab 0 Jahren sich schwaffeln.
Weil?
Also ich würde das Wahlrecht eingrenzen wollen auf die Leute, die sich informieren. Also es darf nur der wählen, der sich genügend über die Sache informiert hat.
Aber wer soll denn das Test geben oder bestimmen?
Dann müssen wir das Wahlrecht gleich abschaffen. Nee, die Sache mit dem Wahlrecht ab 0 Jahren ist, dass natürlich solange die Kinder noch nicht alleine das Kreuz machen, halt natürlich möglicherweise die Eltern das Kreuz einfach für die Kinder machen. Aber das sind halt auch Menschen.
Und du meinst jemand, der macht geil ist, der wird dann in Zukunft sich einfach eine unendliche Anzahl von Kindern machen?
Das gibt es doch in arabischen Ländern.
ne, das würde einfach schon dazu führen, dass vermutlich 10 bis 20 Prozent der Bevölkerung, nämlich die unter 18-Jährigen, auch einfach bei der Politik mehr berücksichtigt werden. Das wäre einfach der Effekt.
Ich sage ja gar nicht, das ist nur für Jugendliche gilt. Ich sage auch, dass Leute, die 20 oder 30 sind, die einfach sich damit mit der Sache gar nicht befassen oder so, gerade mit der Politik, dass denen das Wahlrecht genommen wird. Wer sich nicht genügend informiert, darf auch mit abstimmen.
Im Grunde gibt es das ja im Netz, das ist genau das Modell mit den RFCs. Nur diejenigen Leute können Gesetze machen bzw. Entscheidungen fällen, die auch mitreden. Und manche Dinge sind einfach so, dass das nicht alle mitreden.
Aber das System haben wir ja im Prinzip in der parlamentarischen Demokratie. Wenn du nicht mitmachst, kannst du alle fünf Jahre deinen Kreuz machen. Aber wenn du in der Partei bist, hast du statistisch schon mal 20. Ist deine Stimme 20 mal so viel wert wie das Kreuzchen? Du kannst viel öfter abstimmen und deine Meinung sagen. Und wenn du funktionär bist eben auch. Also insofern ist es nicht...
Ist kein neuer Punkt, befürchte ich. Danke trotzdem.
Es wäre mir jetzt auch schwer gefallen, mich davon zu verabschieden. Von dem Wahlrecht ab Null. So, ach nee, eigentlich müssten wir jetzt mal langsam eine Zusammenfassung machen, Anni. Echt? Wir haben noch 6 Minuten.
Echt, wir haben noch 6 Minuten, dann macht noch mal ein bisschen Musik dazu.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, machen wir lieber.
Sehr schön. Wir haben gesammelt am heutigen Abend in der heutigen Nacht. Und wir haben noch kein neues Betriebssystem, aber wir haben Eckpunkte, wir haben Eckdaten. Die sehen aus. Erstmal Dezentralisierung. Das heißt, keine repräsentativen Instanzen, die überfordert sind, weil über alles entscheidend ist. Weniger. Dezentralisierung Transparenz ist aber das allererste Gebot. Also die Dinge müssen erstmal erfahrbar sein, bevor man über sie entscheiden kann. Das heißt natürlich auch, dass gesellschaftliche Kompetenzen herausgebildet werden müssen. Das heißt die Möglichkeit, sich zu informieren, Netze zu nutzen, irgendwie Informationen zu bewerten, Medienkompetenz und alle diese Dinge müssen wesentlich...
Die ersten drei Punkte klingen natürlich zugegebenermaßen etwas allgemein.
Ja gut, die sind alle noch etwas allgemein. Das sind ja auch nur die Eckpunkte.
Ich hab auch noch drei. Ich hab auch noch drei.
Okay, die kannst du dann gleich machen. Also, die Grundrente ist ein wichtiger Punkt, damit erstmal die Existenzängste besiegt sind, weil in einer Gesellschaft mit einem überwiegenden Anteil der Bevölkerung, der unter Existenzängsten liegt, es weder sinnvoll zu diskutieren, noch irgendetwas zu tun.
Also, wenn jeder erstmal grundsätzlich 1000 Mark im Monat kriegen würde, das würde sich sogar fast rechnen. Ich glaub, so 7-800 Mark, so erstmal grundsätzlich für jeden unabhängig vom Einkommen wäre schon...
Okay, also damit die Leute irgendwie von ihren Existenzängsten los sind. Wahlrecht ab Null Jahre, nicht aufregen.
Da möchte ich...
Ja, nicht aufregen, ne, das ist natürlich Blödsinn.
Dass ich hier jetzt sitze, einfach mal aufregen.
Okay, nein, aufregen ist okay. Also aufregen und streiten finde ich auch. Auseinandersetzung, irgendwie Diskussion, das ist schon das, was wir haben wollen. Also wir wollen ja nicht...
Havl hat die ganze Zeit so moralisch argumentiert, das war doch klasse. Das braucht man doch irgendwie mal. Ich vergiss nicht die transparenten Geldkoffer, die waren mir auch wichtig.
Ja, transparente Geldkoffer, genau.
So, dann der Punkt mit den finanziell unabhängigen Foren. Das heißt, eine Diskussionskultur zu schaffen, eine Grundlageinstitution zu schaffen, wo man nicht deswegen, weil man dafür bezahlt wird oder weil man es sich leisten kann, sondern jeder muss sich das leisten können, sich an diesen Dingen zu beteiligen, sich zu informieren. Und jeder muss dazu auch die Zeit haben. Sprich, Arbeitsplätze gibt es ja eh nicht genug, aber es gibt genug zu tun, Arbeit gibt es genug. Die technischen Helden müssen natürlich gesenkt werden. Ein sehr wichtiger Punkt dann, nicht drücken und nicht ziehen, was im Grunde genommen genau da reinfällt. Also die Leute müssen weder in Bedingungen leben, wo sie dem Geld hinterher rennen müssen, weil es ihnen sonst dreckig geht, noch müssen sie irgendwie dazu gezwungen werden, was sie tun. Mitbestimmungsrecht über die Steuern, das heißt eine genaue Auflistung der Optionen. Das kann man elektronisch am Thema machen, wie der Staatshaushalt tatsächlich aussieht.
Jeder kann, was weiß ich, drei Haushaltsposten wegklicken. Damit könnte man zum Beispiel schon mal anfangen.
Also Haushalt, wie nennen wir das Haushalt? Staatshaushalt mit Bestimmung. Ich muss das kurz noch aufschreiben. Ja, die Informationspflichten haben wir hier noch als Punkt. Da ging es um die Transparenzpunkt. Und jetzt wollte Marty noch was ergänzen.
Ja, ich habe natürlich meine persönlichen Punkte. Die heißen Bescheidenheit, Erkenntnis und Liebe. Der Gegenteil davon ist interessant. Der Gegenteil von Bescheidenheit, Erkenntnis und Liebe ist Luxus, Dummheit und Hass. Und das ist genau das, was ich nicht will.
So gesehen ist es okay.
Ist in Ordnung. Ja, dann bleibt uns offenbar auch angesichts der Zeit nur noch euch Frieden auf Erden und eine gute Gesinnung für jedermann zu wünschen. Mut. Mut sowieso.
Und das war eine Schulfunksendung. Also das heißt, die Rechte sind frei und ihr könnt das im Unterricht irgendwie hören. Das ist nämlich normalerweise verboten, wenn ihr das jetzt aufgenommen habt.
Ist aber kein Problem. Und wenn ihr irgendwie mehr über solche Ideen wissen oder mitdiskutieren wollt, dann empfehlen wir euch entweder www.ccc.de. Wir haben auch eine News Group, die ist allerdings vom Niveau her etwa schwankend, aber wir haben einen Diskussionsverteiler. Das ist debateatlists.ccc.de. Da kommt man mit debate-subscribe-atlists.ccc.de drauf. Das ist, glaube ich, noch der sinnvollste Verteiler, den wir im Moment zu bieten haben. Und ansonsten wünschen wir euch Friede auf Erden.
Okay, Chaosradio. Jetzt kommt gleich der Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Chaosradio gibt es wieder immer am letzten Ende, am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Ihr seid bereit im Februar?
Wir sind bereit.
Ja, vielleicht von der Cebit. Also es ist genau Cebit. Wir wissen auch nicht, ob wir es von hier oder von da machen.
Gut, das werden wir dann sehen und hören. Chaosradio mit Pavel, Martin, Andi und ich bin Sabina. Gute Nacht und jetzt viel Spaß mit Martin Petersdorf. Tschüss, hier kommt auch Manfred Krug. Das ist die Tatortplatte.